Hey, I've heard told you guys my life story before. Okay, so, Toronto, May, 1970. Well, it's weird. Over here, I'm getting the red light for you. Oh, that's a nod. You just want to start? Yeah. Welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart.
嘿，我以前好像跟你们讲过我的人生故事。好吧，多伦多，1970年5月。呃，这很奇怪。这边我看到你们的灯变红了。哦，那是点个头。你们想直接开始吗？对。欢迎来到Smartless。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。
Lattice. Hi JB. Hi you guys. So this is your new relax zone. JB's in Brooklyn. This is how I picture it. Now JB's now in New York for a stretch. And I pictured you going there Saturday.
Lattice。嗨，JB。嗨，伙计们。所以这是你们新的放松区。JB在布鲁克林。这就是我脑海中的画面。现在JB要在纽约住上一段时间。我想象你周六会去那儿。
And I asked you, because I was like, I know what you're... Just hear me out. You get to your spot, you drop your stuff, and then you find the spot on the couch where you're perpendicular to the TV. That is so true. Yeah, but I already scouted that though when I had to pick the apartment.
然后我问你，因为我在想，我知道你在……听我说完。你到了地方，放下行李，然后在沙发上找个位置，正好和电视垂直。太对了。对，但我其实在选公寓的时候就已经踩过点啦。
I had to make sure there was an L-type configuration in front of the TV. Rest of the apartment I don't care about. It doesn't matter. I just need to know I've got a nesting spot. Are you happy with the apartment? I am. Oh, good. I'm very happy, but you know, I'm a soft guy.
我得确保电视机前面有L型的布局。公寓的其他部分我根本不在乎。无所谓。我只需要知道我有个能蜷缩着待的地方。你对这套公寓满意吗？我很满意。哦，太好了。我很满意，但你知道，我是个内心柔软的人。
I'm prone to homesickness. It's lonely, I mean I live with three incredible women and now I'm all alone, but what did I have to sort of buoy my spirits? A pair of brand new slippers. The waiting for me in the apartment from sweet, sweet Shawnee. Yeah, how about that? Is that true Shawnee?
我很容易想家。这很孤单，我是说我原本和三个了不起的女人住在一起，现在我孤身一人，但有什么能稍微振奋一下我的精神呢？一双全新的拖鞋。在公寓里等我呢，来自甜心肖妮。对，怎么样？真的吗，肖妮？
Yes, I got Willie something for his ankles and I got Jason. You did. I mean, did you get him some running weights for his ankles? No, he got me that thing to stretch my calves because I've been having my hamstring issue. And I sent you slippers because I know that-
是的，我给威利买了一些护脚踝的东西，还给杰森买了。你买的。我是说，你给他买了一些脚踝负重沙袋吗？没有，他给我买了个拉伸小腿的仪器，因为我的腿筋一直有问题。我给你寄拖鞋是因为我知道——
But Shawnee, as I said in the text, you're not supposed to be well raised. I know I'm not well raised. We were kind of raised by wolves. But I think that's probably why, right? Yeah. But isn't it true though, like because I was thinking about you being alone there
但是肖妮，就像我在短信里说的，你可不是在教养良好的家庭长大的。我知道我教养不好。我们差不多是由狼抚养长大的。但我想这可能就是原因吧？对。不过难道不是吗，因为我在想你一个人在那边，
and I was like, isn't it nice to have just something soft like that or whatever it is. Like slip, I texted you like slippers to me make a home. Yeah. Once you have slippers, then you feel like you're like. Or an L-shaped couch in front of an L-shaped. Sean, how come every time you say it's nice to have something soft you seem to grab on your belly
然后我就在想，有双那样软乎乎的东西或者随便什么感觉真好，对吧。就像拖鞋，我发短信给你说，对我来说拖鞋才像个家。对。一旦有了拖鞋，你就会觉得你像是在。或者电视机前面有个L形沙发。肖恩，为什么每次你说有双软乎乎的东西真好时，你好像都会抓住自己的肚子，
and you just give it a nice. I couldn't mail my belly. The cookie pouch. Oh, I miss it. How are you guys doing? What's going on back home? So listen, my thing is, I think I, well, Will FaceTimed me and I answered it from the ER, right?
然后轻轻地捏一下。我可没法给我的肚子寄快递。曲奇小肚腩。哦，我想念它。你们最近怎么样？家里有什么新鲜事？所以听着，我的情况是，我想我，呃，威尔用FaceTime打给我，我是从急诊室接通的，对吧？
Not just that, we had been, I had seen him for lunch. Yeah. Okay, we had this lunch meeting with, and JB, you would have been there, but you were traveling, so we had this lunch meeting. I don't know, 90 minutes later, I FaceTime Sean to ask him something.
不仅如此，我们，我之前刚和他吃过午餐。对。好吧，我们和——JB，你本该在那儿的，但你在旅行，所以我们有个午餐会。我不记得了，90分钟后，我用FaceTime打给肖恩问他点事。
And he's on a- He's in the back of an ambulance. No dude, he's on a gurney. He's on a gurney in the hall at Cedars. Angel, what happened? And I go, what the fuck is going on? Yeah, no, I got the AFib thing again, and you guys know. And they just, I talked about it on the tour.
然后他正在——他在救护车的后厢里。不，老兄，他躺在担架上。他躺在锡达斯西奈医院大厅的担架上。天哪，发生什么事了？我说，这到底是怎么回事？对，不，我的房颤又犯了，你们也知道的。我在巡演的时候就聊过这个。
And that's where Jimmy Kimmel gave me the nickname of Paddle. So I texted Jimmy and I said Paddle's is at it again. And I took a picture and I texted it to Jimmy of me in my gown all hooked up to the wires. And yeah, I just said AFib. And so they put me out, they paddled, they zapped my heart. So for the medical Tracy's out there,
吉米·坎摩尔就是在那时候给我起了个外号叫“电击器”（Paddle）。所以我给吉米发短信说，电击器的老毛病又犯了。我还拍了张照片发给吉米，照片里的我穿着病号服，身上连满了电线。是的，我只说了句房颤。所以他们把我麻醉了，电击了，给我的心脏除颤了。所以对于医学爱好者来说，
AFib is what, it's just an irregular heartbeat? Yeah, it's atrial fibrillation, so some people are in it all the time and they don't know it. I know when I get it, which is a good thing, because then I can go to the ER. Here's the worst part, or the best part. Your heart just raced.
房颤是什么，它只是一种心律不齐吗？对，就是心房颤动，有些人一直处于这种状态却浑然不知。我知道自己什么时候发作，这其实是件好事，因为这样我就可以去急诊室了。最糟糕的是，或者说最好的是。你的心跳刚刚飙升了。
Here's the best part, so we're at this lunch, again, business lunch. The guy says, you guys want anything, you guys want anything, he's gonna Oh the guy says you guys want anything you guys want anything at the end? He's gonna bring the check you guys wanted you want a coffee or somebody said I'll take a coffee our buddy Rick is there Rick Kay Rick says I'll take a coffee too and Sean says that's the guys walking around walking away. I'll take a milkshake He goes he goes just by the way just vanilla just have dessert for lunch. It's noon and he goes, he goes, he goes, just, by the way, just vanilla, just vanilla. And I said, and I said, and if you've got any paddles, bring them to the table.
最棒的是，我们在吃午餐，又是商务午餐。那家伙说，你们想要点什么吗，你们想要点什么吗，他最后要——哦，那家伙说你们想要点什么吗，你们想要点什么吗，他最后要来买单，你们要不要咖啡，或者有人说我来杯咖啡，我们的朋友里克也在，里克·凯，里克说我也来杯咖啡，然后肖恩在服务员走开的时候说。我来杯奶昔。他接着说，顺便来点香草味的，把甜点当午餐吃。现在才中午，他说，他接着说，顺便说一句，就要香草味，只要香草味。我说，我说，如果你们有电击器的话，顺便带到桌上来。
Oh no. Oh my God, I forgot you said that. So 90 minutes later, he's in the hallway at fucking Cedars and if I get on a gurney and I'm like, oh fuck. Those gowns are beautiful though. If he goes down from this today and I've suggested the paddles, I'm really gonna feel badly for a couple weeks.
噢不。天哪，我都忘了你说过这话了。所以90分钟后，他躺在锡达斯西奈医院该死的走廊里，如果我躺在担架上，我肯定会想，噢操。不过那些病号服真好看。如果他今天因此倒下，而我又建议了电击器，那我接下来的几个星期都会觉得很内疚的。
So you get into the, okay, so you feel the heart is racing, I should get to an emergency room because things might unravel from here. Like it doesn't fix itself. You need to go in there and you literally need to get like a jump start to get it. It's like restarting a car or something. But they put you out, which is great.
所以你到了，好吧，当你感觉到心跳加速时，我得去急诊室，因为接下来情况可能会彻底恶化。这病不会自己好。你必须去医院，字面意义上需要像汽车启动一样给它来个电击重启。就像重启汽车什么的。不过他们会把你麻醉，这很棒。
And of course, I always try to think of something. Oh, by the way, I read the thing. Wait, we'll cut out this air that takes me to find this. This is worth it. This is great. We can have some music. We can play some music now. Sorry, mystery guest. Just hang on. Shawn's got props. Shawn's got some stuff in there.
当然，我总是试着想点什么。哦，对了，我读了那个东西。等等，我们把这段剪掉吧，这花了我不少时间才找到。这很值得。这太棒了。我们可以放点音乐。我们现在可以放点音乐了。抱歉，神秘嘉宾。请稍等。肖恩带了道具。肖恩带了一些东西过来。
So I said, she starts going, she starts going, because this is what they do every time. Who's she? The doctor in the ER. This is what they do, because I've been cardioversion, it's called cardioversion. And I've had this done to me like 15 times. So she starts gathering the anesthesiologist,
所以我说，她开始，她开始，因为急诊室里的人每次都这样。谁是“她”？急诊室的女医生。他们每次都这样，因为我做过心脏复律，这叫心脏复律。这手术我已经做过大概15次了。于是她开始召集麻醉师，
two nurses, her, somebody else, I don't know. There was like five or six people there. And they stand around the bed right before the procedure and they have to announce all this stuff. And as she's getting into it, I say, do you mind if I take over? And she goes, sure. I go, okay, everyone, the patient's name is Sean Hayes,
两个护士，她自己，还有另外某个人，我不知道。当时大概有五六个人在那里。手术开始前他们站在病床周围，必须宣读所有这些流程。就在她准备开始时，我说，你介意让我来吗？她回答说，当然。我说，好的，各位，病人的名字是肖恩·海斯，
date of birth is 6-26-70, we're treating him today for atrial fibrillation. We're gonna use 10 milligrams of Atomidate and we're gonna attempt cardioversion. Everybody okay? And she goes, she's like, what? Nobody's ever done that. She goes, yeah, now we're ready.
出生日期是1970年6月26日，我们今天为他治疗的病症是心房颤动。我们将使用10毫克依托咪酯，并尝试进行心脏复律。大家都没问题吧？然后她露出一副，什么？的表情。从来没有人这么干过。她说，好吧，现在我们准备好了。
That's how often I've had this done. Oh my God. God, you will do anything for applause. So what about maybe buying your own set of paddles? Oh, that's a great idea. No, I thought about it. And just doing like small, why don't you turn the garage into an ER?
我这手术做得有多频繁可想而知。天哪。天哪，你为了博得掌声可真是什么都做得出来。那要不考虑自己买一套电击器呢？哦，这主意真不错。不，我考虑过。干脆弄个小型的，你为什么不把车库改成急诊室呢？
Or just a section of it near the washer dryer where maybe Scotty can just kind of bang you back into rhythm. Yeah, they can teach Scotty. My friend Robert has paddles at his house, like a whole thing. Truly. Wow. All right, well, like a whole thing. What, truly, wow. All right, well, so I'd love to circle back to, and I'm sorry, guests, we're gonna get right to you,
或者就在靠近洗衣机烘干机的那片区域隔出一块，也许斯科特可以在那儿帮你把心律拍回正轨？对，他们可以教斯科特。我的朋友罗伯特家里就备有电击器，是一整套设备。真的。哇。好吧，那——像一整套设备。什么，真的，哇。好吧，所以我想把话题转回来——抱歉，嘉宾，我们马上就会聊到你，
but I'd love to get you to stop drinking ice cream for lunch. I know. You're right. You know, so let's just start to just kinda chip away at maybe the problem before. How is that gonna happen? Dude, he's got the maker at home problem. How is that going to happen? Dude, he's got the maker at home now.
但我真希望你能戒掉午餐吃冰激凌的习惯。我知道。你说得对。所以我们还是试着从根源上解决一下以前的问题吧。那怎么可能做到？老兄，他现在有居家制造商的问题了。那怎么可能做到？老兄，他现在有居家阿什拉姆（修行所）制造商了。你忘啦。这跟那个没关系。这只是因为我吃了一颗软糖。说来话长。哦。
Now he's got the ashram maker. You forget. It doesn't have anything to do with that. It just has, it's because I had a gummy. It's a long conversation. Oh. Yeah, I don't stumble into Afib. If it was because of the gummies, we'd be talking to JB.
对，我可不是随便就得房颤的。如果是因为软糖的话，那我们现在就得跟JB通话了。
He'd be at fucking, he'd be at New York Presbyterian right now. As would the entire country, now that it's all legal and people are enjoying it. But if you're prone to it, like I am, then it's like a trigger. Listen, I don't wanna mention, I don't wanna cut in because we don't have a lot of time because there's gonna be air so far away from it,
他现在肯定已经在——他现在就在纽约长老会医院了。就像全国其他人一样，既然这玩意儿现在全面合法了，大家都在享受呢。但如果你本身就像我一样是个易发体质，那它就像是个导火索。听着，我不想提这事，我不想打断你们，因为我们时间不多了，离正题还有点远，
but I, instead of going there, I went to the All-Star Game and I coached Connor McDavid and I was the co-captain with Connor McDavid. That's right. Get to Willie's All-Star game and I coached Connor McDavid and I was the co-captain with Connor McDavid. That's right Willie's All-Star weekend. I just it's really quick. I had a hockey nirvana. It was a fucking it was unbelievable I finally met Wendell Clark for the first time I that was the first time you met him I was sure Tracy Wendell Clark is a very very famous ex hockey player that will is is is such a fan of
不过我，我没去那个地方，而是去了全明星赛，我还执教了康纳·麦克戴维，我和康纳·麦克戴维一起担任联合队长。没错。赶上威利的全明星赛了，我还执教了康纳·麦克戴维，与他一同担任联合队长。没错，威利的周末全明星赛。我只想说——这真的很短暂。我简直置身于冰球极乐世界。这太他妈——这太难以置信了，我终于第一次见到了温德尔·克拉克，我——那是你第一次见他？我原本确信——特雷西，温德尔·克拉克是一位非常非常著名的前冰球运动员，威尔是他的超级大粉丝，
that your avatar on your texting is... I didn't know who he is. Even Sean knows. He gets golf balls with just the 19 on them because that was Wendell's number. 17, 17. JB last year for my birthday very sweetly got Wendell to make me a video and then sent me some signed stuff
以至于你发短信时的头像都是……我以前根本不知道他是谁。连肖恩都知道。他甚至定制了印有“19”字样的的高尔夫球，因为那是温德尔的球衣号码。17，17。JB去年在我生日时非常贴心地请温德尔给我录了一段视频，还寄给我一些签名纪念品，
and that blew me away. Cameo, cameo? Not even a cameo, no, no, no. He went and got in touch with him and it was very sweet. So anyway, I saw him in an elevator. I said, I didn't expect that this is how it was gonna happen but I met him in an elevator and it was just unbelievable. And I got, I coached, well coach, fuck,
这让我震撼极了。是Cameo网站（名人祝福视频平台）定制的吗？甚至都不是Cameo，不，不，不。他亲自去联系了他，这真的太贴心了。总之，我在电梯里碰到了他。我说，我没想到事情会以这种方式发生，但我确实在电梯里见到了他，这简直难以置信。而且我还去执教了，教练，操，
I just stood there like a dink. No, they said, what do you wanna do, coach? I'm like, who wants to hear from a stupid actor? What are you talking about? I'm just here to- Yeah, were you down in like the locker room having to give like a rah rah speech? Yeah, I gave a speech. So I gave are you talking about? I'm just here to- Yeah, were you down in the locker room having to give a rah rah speech? Yeah, I gave a speech.
我当时就像个呆子一样站在那儿。不，他们问，教练，你想做点什么？我说，谁想听一个蠢演员瞎比比啊？你在说什么呢？我来这儿就是为了——对，你当时是在更衣室里发表那种鼓舞士气的演讲吗？对，我发表了一演讲。所以我发表了——你在说什么呢？我来这儿就是为了——对，你当时是在更衣室里发表鼓舞士气的演讲吗？对，我发表了一演讲。
So I gave a speech, and so what I did was- So who? Who was on your team? Connor McDavid, Leon Dreisaitl. We had David Pasternak from the Bruins. I had Brody Jenner from- We had fucking Connor Hellebuck, the greatest goalie in the league right now.
所以我发表了演讲，我当时做的是——那么是谁？谁在你的队伍里？康纳·麦克戴维、莱昂·德拉萨特。我们还有来自棕熊队的大卫·帕斯特纳克。我们还有来自——我们有他妈的康纳·海勒布克，目前联盟中最伟大的守门员。
And for a pregame speech, Peter Laviollette, the Hall of Fame coach, was next to me. And I said, let me give the speech. And I put together from a different sport, all great quotes I strung together from Jürgen Klopp, my guy at Liverpool. And I made a speech about it. And it was like, it literally was, it was ridiculous.
在赛前的更衣室讲话时，名人堂教练彼得·拉维奥列特就站在我旁边。我说，让我来做这个演讲。于是我把从另一个运动项目中收集到的各种伟大的名言警句串联起来，这些话都出自于尤尔根·克洛普，我在利物浦的偶像。我围绕这些做了一场演讲。那场面简直——说实话，太荒谬了。
I think I lost him at the end when I said, when I first came to Dortmund, and they're like, what? Dortmund? Anyway, it was fantastic. we had a great time, and I don't wanna spend too much time, but it was so cool. Did Wendell Clark knew who you are?
我想当我在最后说出“当我刚来到多特蒙德时”的时候，他们可能已经一头雾水了，心想：什么？多特蒙德？不管怎样，太棒了。我们度过了一段美妙的时光，我不想占用太多时间，但那真的太酷了。温德尔·克拉克知道你是谁吗？
Yeah, he did actually, I will say that. And his wife saw that I was like, and she nudged him, because he didn't see me at first, and then it was sick. And then I got to say to my dad, we walked down and I said, and I see Wayne Gretzky, and I said, Wayne, have you ever met my dad? He's like, no, and my dad was like, it was unbelievable.
对，他其实知道，我得承认这一点。他的妻子看到我时，还用胳膊肘碰了他一下，因为他一开始没看见我，那感觉简直酷毙了。然后我走过去对爸爸说，我们走过去时我看到了韦恩·格雷茨基，我说，韦恩，你见过我爸爸吗？他说没有，我爸爸当时那个表情，简直太不可思议了。
That's crazy that Wayne Gretzky and I say, Wayne, have you ever met my dad? He's like, no, and my dad was like, it was unbelievable. That's crazy that Wayne Gretzky was there. The whole weekend. That's the, the little guy makes good. He comes back home and. It's funny you say that. So the last thing I'll say is so Abel, you guys know my 13 year old, he says to me the other night and he goes,
韦恩·格雷茨基也在现场，这太疯狂了。整个周末都在。这就是小人物出头之日啊。他衣锦还乡了，然后。你这么说真有意思。所以我要说的最后一件事是，阿贝尔，你们知道我那个13岁的儿子，他前天晚上对我说，
look, I'm going to check and make sure he's doing his homework and he goes, dad, I'm really proud of you. I said, and I go, what do you mean? I go, what are you talking about? We hadn't been talking about it. He goes, well, probably the little kid version of you didn't think that you'd ever be there
听着，我过去检查他有没有写完作业，他对我说，爸爸，我真的为你感到骄傲。我问，我说，什么意思？我说，你在说什么呢？我们之前又没聊过这个。他说，嗯，小时候的那个你大概怎么也不会想到，你有一天会站在全明星赛的现场，做着你做过的事。他还说，我不知道儿子为爸爸感到骄傲是不是有点奇怪，但我真的为你感到骄傲。然后他走过来拥抱了我，还在我头上亲了一下。太贴心了。天哪，你当时肯定感动得稀里哗啦吧。
at the All-Star Game doing what you did. And he goes, I don't know if it's weird for a son to be proud of his dad, but I'm really proud of you. And then he came up and he gave me a hug, and he kissed me on the head. It was so sweet. Oh, God, you must have fucking fallen apart.
他真是个贴心的孩子，我确实感动得稀里哗啦的。你这个多愁善感的家伙。他能说出这样的话，真的很像个老成持重的人。对，非常老成。我也要哭了，所以我得打住。我太喜欢这个了。真的很幸运。不过，他们当时没有跟你一起去吧，对吗？
He's such a sweet kid, and I did fall apart. You big softy. That's very like old soul of him to say. Yeah, very old soul. I'm gonna cry too, so I'm gonna stop. I love that. Really lucky. Now, they weren't there with you, were they?
他们不能去，不，纯粹是因为要上学，如果去的话会落下太多天的功课，而且他们现在一个上初中，一个上高中。但你把那边的见闻都告诉他们了吧？天哪，我在比赛进行时直接用FaceTime从替补席连线了阿贝尔。我当时就喊，我听不清你们说话。威利，他们是冰球迷吗？
They couldn't, no, just because of school, it was too many days away from school and they're in middle school and high school. But you filled them in. Oh my God, I FaceTimed Abe from the bench as the game was going on. And I was just like, I can't hear you. Are they hockey fans, Will?
算是吧，没有那么狂热，因为他们在加州长大，不过，总之，我们已经占用了嘉宾太多的时间，我们的嘉宾可不值得我在这里喋喋不休。不过真的很酷，我敢打赌嘉宾现在肯定在哭呢。他们需要一点时间来平复一下心情。我——我觉得不会，不过我不知道。
Ish, not as much because they grew up in California, but yeah, anyway, we've taken up so much time of our guests and our guest doesn't deserve to have me ramble on. Pretty awesome though, I bet you the guest is crying right now. They need a little time to get it together. I don't, I doubt it, but I don't know.
但这个人——这真的很酷，威利。对，谢谢。是的，这真的是千载难逢的经历，非同寻常。说到非同寻常，你知道我最喜欢搞这种顺势过渡了。是的，非常优美。我们正在谈论非同寻常的天才，因为我们的嘉宾，她是一位绝对非同寻常的艺术家、演员、电影制作人。
But this person- That's pretty cool, Will. Yeah, thanks. Yeah, it was once in a lifetime and it was extraordinary. And speaking of extraordinary, you know I love my segues. Yes, beautiful. We're talking extraordinary talent because our guest, she is an absolutely extraordinary artist, actor, filmmaker.
她曾获得过奥斯卡金像奖提名。她赢得过22个影评人奖项。拜托。就这？哦，对。她还拿过金球奖，各种大奖应有尽有。她是历史上第一个获得凯撒奖（法国奥斯卡）的美国人。感谢你对这个词的发音。对，谢谢。凯撒，你刚才怎么说，发音是这样的。凯撒（法语发音）。对于……
She'd been nominated for an Academy Award. She's won 22 Critics Awards. Come on. That's it? Oh yeah. She won Golden Globes, all of it. She's the first American ever to be awarded a César Award, the French Oscars. Appreciate the pronunciation on that. Yeah, thank you. César, what do you say, pronunciation on that. Césaire. For the...
《香烟云》（Clouds of Sils Maria）。喝咖啡。我抽一支烟，等等，去见我的爱人，喝杯咖啡。她出演过一些有史以来最伟大的电影。
Clouds of Cigarettes. To coffee. I take one cigarette, I wait, I meet up with my lover, I have a coffee. And she's just been in some of the biggest films of all time.
她很年轻的时候就参演过史上最庞大的系列电影之一，我猜这段经历一直贯穿了她的整个二十多岁。真难以置信她竟然只有，我想，33岁。这很难想象，因为她已经完成了如此多非同寻常的作品。她即将开启新篇章。她将主演她的新电影，这部电影上映的时间大概就在我们录制……资料做得很棒。真有你的。
She's been in one of the hugest franchises ever at a very young age and took her through her 20s, I would imagine. I can't believe that she's only, I think, 33. It's hard to imagine because she's done so much extraordinary work. And she's about to start. She's going to be in her new film, which is being released around the time that we're doing... Good research. Good for you.
我敢肯定现在制片厂看到你掐准上映日期一定激动坏了。不，我懂，但是……她的笑声真好听。这一点我们知道了。她简直急不可耐地想要出场了。我literally（简直）在想……我打赌她知道具体日期。你这个笨蛋，怎么不直接介绍她上场呢？不，他们告诉我日期了，我想拿——但预告片看起来太棒了。《爱欲lie布林》（Love Lies Bleeding）。
I'm sure the studio is thrilled right now as you're watching for the date. No, I know, but... She's got a great laugh. We know that much. She's dying to appear. I'm literally trying to think... I bet she's got the date. Why don't you introduce her, you numb nut? No, they gave me the date and I want to get... But the trailers look so amazing. Love Lies Bleeding.
A24出品的这部电影看起来太棒了。总之，伙计们，她就是克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。哦，哇！克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特！伙计们！敢信吗？克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特！你到底为什么要答应来上这个播客？
It looks so amazing from A24. Anyway, guys, it's Kristen Stewart. Oh, wow! Kristen Stewart! Guys! Can you believe this? Kristen Stewart! What are you doing saying yes to this podcast?
人也太好了吧。快去炒了你的公关吧。备受折磨，还得坐在这儿听我们折磨。我知道，真的很抱歉让你经历这些。嗨。嘿。最近怎么样？我的心现在扑通扑通跳呢。我不知道这是不是——真的很抱歉让你经历这些。嗨。嘿。嗨。最近怎么样？
What a nice person. Fire your publicist. Tortured, sitting through our torture. I know, I'm so sorry to put you through that. Hi. Hey. How's it going? My heart is pounding now. I don't know if it'm so sorry to put you through that. Hi. Hey. Hi. How's it going?
我的心现在扑通扑通跳呢。我不知道这算不算是因为刚听了你们讨论你那破心脏，反正我的心脏感觉也不太妙。我的心脏挺糟糕的。好吧，因为听别人聊天挺有意思的。你坐在这儿听播客，然后就会忘记其实轮到自己上节目了，
My heart is pounding now. I don't know if it's like the initial conversation about your shitty heart, but mine's not like. Mine's pretty shitty. Well, because listening is interesting. You sit around and listen to the podcast and you forget you have to go on it
因为听你们聊天很有趣，接着你就会想，哦不。其实也没那么糟。只有当嘉宾登场时节目才真正变得精彩。对，电话连线现在正式开始。你好，欢迎。对，欢迎克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。很高兴见到你。然后你就会想，哦不。其实也没那么糟。只有当嘉宾登场时节目才真正变得精彩。你好，欢迎。欢迎，克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。很高兴见到你。谢谢你来参加节目。
because it's like fun to listen to you guys and then you're like, oh no. It's not that great. It only gets great when the guest comes on. Yeah, the phone starts now. Hello and welcome. Yeah, welcome Christian Stewart. So nice to meet you. then you're like, oh no. It's not that great. It only gets great when the guest comes on. Hello and welcome. Welcome, Kristen Stewart. So nice to meet you. Thank you for doing this.
哦，她手里拿的是咖啡饮料吗，克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特？哦，对。这是什么咖啡？是奶昔吗？是绿色的吗？不，不是。不，这个杯子上有小花呢。哦，真可爱。
Oh, does she have a coffee drink, Kristen Stewart? Oh yeah. What kind of coffee is that? Is it a shake? Is it green? No, it's not. No, there's little flowers on this cup. Oh, cute.
克里斯蒂安，我一直在想这个，能给我们简单讲讲你早晨的咖啡日常吗？你通常喝什么？我对这个开场太感兴趣了。对，太棒了。别担心，这绝对不是什么尖锐的访谈。全都是废话。
You know what I was thinking about this, Kristen, walk us through your coffee routine in the morning, if you will, real quick. What's your go-to? I'm so into the start of this. Yeah, great. Don't worry, this will not be hard-hitting at all. It's a bunch of garbage.
不，咖啡其实是我最近才开始接触的东西。我以前从来不在早晨喝任何饮料。我总是硬扛过去，后来我才发现这玩意儿有多好玩。哦，对。一点微弱的兴奋剂。所以，你醒来后会立刻下楼或者去厨房煮咖啡，还是会间隔一会儿？你通常煮什么咖啡？我对这个过程非常感兴趣。
No, coffee is like only something that I kind of recently got into. I never used to have any morning beverages. I just would barrel through and then I realized how fun it was. Oh yeah,. Little stimuli. So, do you wake up and go immediately downstairs or wherever into the kitchen and make coffee, or do you have a gap? And what kind of coffee do you make? I am very interested in this process.
所以，有一段时间，我会，呃，试着做浓缩咖啡，但我很不擅长。我压出来的咖啡液总是水水的，而且怪怪的。对。而且还是大清早刚醒的时候。你根本没有这方面的技能。我有点——咖啡液总是水水的，而且怪怪的。对。而且还是大清早刚醒的时候。你根本没有这方面的技能。我有点——刚从床上爬起来。比如说，我需要保持安静，以免，呃，惹恼我的家人。你这话是什么意思，你……
So, for a while, I would, like, try and make espresso, but I'm not good at it. All of my poles are watery and weird. Yeah. First thing in the morning, too. You don't have skills. I'm kind of a it. All of my poles are watery and weird. Yeah. First thing in the morning, too. You don't have skills. I'm kind of a being out of bed. Like, I need to be quiet in order to not kind of, like, infuriate my family. What do you mean you take...
哦，真的吗？因为你一醒来就随时准备好开聊了。对。对，我一醒来就能，比如，进行全方位的对话。比如，哦，嘿，干嘛呢？你刚才在干嘛？你在想什么？哦，你在想……哦，天哪，我太太完全就是那样。克里斯，我也那样。我非常像那样。我才不是那样。好吧，肖恩——我也那样。我非常像那样。我才不是那样。
Oh, really? Because when you wake up, you're ready to go. Yeah. Yeah, I can wake up having, like, a full conversation. Like, oh, hey, what's up? What have you been doing? What are you thinking about? Oh, are you thinking about... Oh, my God, my wife's exactly like that. Chris, I'm like that, too. I'm very much like that. I'm not like that. Well, Sean'm like that too. I'm very much like that. I'm not like that.
好吧，肖恩，我们别讨论你的睡眠卫生了。简直是一场灾难。比你的心脏还要糟。你得起床，你得下楼，你得坐上车，开车去斯科特住的地方。然后……
Well, Sean, let's not get into your sleep hygiene. It's a fucking disaster. It's worse than your heart. You gotta get out of your bed, you gotta go downstairs, you gotta get in your car, drive over to where Scottie lives. And then... I've got the coffee maker that you can program the night before so you wake up
我有那种可以前一天晚上设定好定时功能的咖啡机，所以当你醒来时，
and it's already a full pot of coffee So it's it's it's grump and idiot proof. Is it just regular coffee JB? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah So just right so I I got it I don't know when maybe two years ago and I thought about this morning as I fuck I'm such a creature habit I never deviate no matter where I am. I go downstairs I turn on the kettle then I fire up the Nespresso machine, and I make two, a double Nespresso, little bit of brown sugar, and then I pour in, so I do Americano style.
已经有一整壶咖啡泡好了。所以它对笨蛋和白痴来说是绝对零失误的。那是普通的咖啡吗，JB？对。对。对。所以我就——我不知道是什么时候，大概两年前吧，今天早上我还想呢，操，我真是个习惯的动物，无论我在哪儿都绝不改变。我下楼，打开水壶，然后启动雀巢胶囊咖啡机，我做两份，双份雀巢浓缩咖啡，加一点红糖，然后我倒进去——所以我是美式咖啡的做法。
Oh yeah, I was gonna say, what's the kettle for? Yeah, and then, so a little hot water, and then. Just so it looks like country and. No, no, no, no, cause. No, just cause, I don't know, Nespresso has made it so easy. I don't know if you've tried Nespresso. I mean, instead of trying to make espresso, Nespresso should be pretty good. Bear with him, Chris, and he's looking for a free machine.
哦，对了，我正想问，要水壶干嘛？对，然后，加一点热水，然后——只是为了看起来像乡村风格……不，不，不，不，因为……不，只是因为，我不知道，雀巢让这一切变得太简单了。我不知道你有没有试过雀巢。我是说，与其费劲去煮浓缩咖啡，雀巢应该算挺不错的了。克里斯，别跟他一般见识，他这是在骗免费咖啡机呢。
I'm not. I'm not. I don't need, I got 160 bucks. Say Nespresso one more time, you'll get one. I've got 160 bucks. No, I'm not, by the way, Clooney owns part of Nespresso, I think, so like I'm not going to give Clooney owns part of Nespresso. I think so like I'm not gonna give Clooney anymore dough But anyway, that is my progress anyway, hi Kristen Stuart guest talk, huh?
我才没有。我才没有。我不需要，我有160美元呢。你再多说一遍“雀巢”这俩字，你就能白拿一台了。我有160美元呢。不，我不是——顺便说一句，克鲁尼拥有雀巢的一部分股份，我想，所以我才不打算——克鲁尼拥有雀巢的一部分股份，我想，所以我才不打算再给克鲁尼送钱了。不过总之，那就是我的进展，总之，嗨，克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特，嘉宾环节来喽？
Kristen where are you today? I'm in LA Did you grow did you grow up out in LA? I did actually I was bored I'm like I'm my first house that I ever lived in was in Topanga, like at the base of Topanga. No way. On the valley side or the beach side? Valley side, obviously. Oh really?
克里斯蒂安，你今天在哪个城市？我在洛杉矶。你在洛杉矶长大吗？是的，其实是的。我很无聊，我想——我住过的第一栋房子在托潘加，就在托潘加的山脚下。不会吧。是在山谷那边还是海滩那边？当然是山谷那边。哦，真的吗？
That's literally, that's right where I grew up. I grew up, so you know Gary's Market there on the corner of Dumetz and Topanga. Oh my God, you freak. My house is next door. Literally, my backyard, like my fence overlooked the parking lot and I would always peek through the gate and be like, I'm spying on people. That was my loop with my bike. I lived in a house between DuMetz and Kanoga,
那简直——那正是我长大的地方。我长大的地方，你知道杜梅茨街和托潘加交界拐角处的加里市场吗？天哪，你这个怪胎。我家就在隔壁。真的，我的后院，我的栅栏正好俯瞰着那个停车场，我总是透过大门往里偷看，心想：我在监视大家呢。那是我骑自行车兜风必经的一段路。我住在杜梅茨街上，在托潘加和卡诺加之间，
or sorry, between Topang and Kanoga on DuMetz, like till I was 15, 16. That is crazy. This just sounds like a Tom Petty song. So we're Woodland Hills kids. See, the valley's not that bad. I take great pride, actually. I like being a little scumbag who literally, like,
或者说，在杜梅茨街上靠近托潘加和卡诺加的那段，一直住到我15、6岁。这太疯狂了。听起来简直像是一首汤姆·佩蒂的歌。所以我们都是伍德兰希尔斯（Woodland Hills）的孩子。看吧，山谷地区其实没那么糟。我其实挺引以为傲的。我喜欢当个小混混，字面意义上那种，
gets high off the smell of a 7-Eleven. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There was an old van story. JB, I just saw JB's face Chris And you just made him so happy because he's no stories about being in Woodland Hills with his skateboard on the bus Right. Yeah, and I and I live in the 7-eleven store. I learned I learned I play Pac-Man asteroids everything in there I just live in there all day long little hostess, you know cake
闻到7-11便利店的味道就能飘飘欲仙的人。哦，对。对，对，对。有一个关于面包车的旧故事。JB，我刚看到JB的表情，克里斯，你把他逗得太开心了，因为他有好多关于在伍德兰希尔斯踩着滑板坐公交车的青春回忆，对吧？对，没错。而且我住在7-11便利店里。我在那儿学会了玩吃豆人、太空侵略者，所有的游戏，我整天就泡在那儿，吃点小蛋糕，你知道的……
Oh my god, what was it like growing up Chris? Like, were you like, Jay, did you have a skateboard? Did you play video games? What was it? Did you have siblings? All of those things. Yeah. All three of them, yeah. I would sit outside of my brother's room and watch him play video games until he would
天哪，克里斯，你小时候是什么样的？比如，你有滑板吗？你玩电子游戏吗？是什么样的？你有兄弟姐妹吗？所有这些都有吗。对。全都占了，是的。我会坐在我哥哥的房间外面，看他玩电子游戏，直到他肯——
like, let me enter. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Really? Did you go to school out there? Did you go to Serenia or Parkman or Taft? This is so weird. I feel like you talk about the valley, but it's a big place, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
让我进去一起玩。对，对，对。真的吗？你在那边上学吗？你上过塞雷尼亚小学、帕克曼小学还是塔夫脱高中？这太诡异了。我觉得你们在讨论山谷地区，但那地方其实挺大的，你知道吗？对，对，对。
I went to Serenia Elementary School and I walked there every day. That's where I went to grade school until sixth grade. You guys, guess what else? You were both child actors. What? There's something in the water out there telling you. We'll be right back. SmartList is supported by Liquid IV. I don't know about you guys,
我上的是塞雷尼亚小学，我每天都步行去上学。那是我就读的小学，一直读到六年级。伙计们，你们猜怎么着？你们俩都是童星。什么？那地方的水土简直自带某种魔力。我们马上回来。SmartList由Liquid I.V.赞助支持。不知道你们怎么样，
but hydration I take very seriously. And every single morning I chug down a bottle of water with Liquid IV added to it. It's one and done. I enjoy like the feeling it gives my body and the results from having it inside my body. Whether you hydrate to live or live to hydrate, Liquid IV quenches your thirst faster than water alone.
但我对水分补充这事非常重视。每天早晨，我都会猛灌一瓶加入了Liquid I.V.的水。一步到位。我很享受它带给身体的感觉以及它进到体内后产生的效果。无论你是为了活着而补水，还是为了补水而活着，Liquid I.V.为你解渴的速度都比单纯喝水更快。
With three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients for everyday wellness. All you need to do is snag your favorite sugar-free stick and 16 ounces of water, and you're on your way to hydration just like I do. So why I chug my liquid IV every single morning is because I know that for the rest of the day I don't have to worry about it as
它含有普通运动饮料三倍的电解质，外加八种支持日常健康的维生素和营养成分。你只需要准备一根你最喜欢的无糖粉条和16盎司的水，就能像我一样开启补水之旅。我每天早上都要猛灌Liquid I.V.的原因是，我知道在接下来的一整天里，我都无需为此担心，
much knowing I have liquid IV inside of me. I do drink throughout the day other water and stuff but having it first thing in the morning I love it. However you hydrate grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20% off your first order when you go to liquid IV comm and use code smartless at checkout that's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code smartless at liquid IV comm this show is sponsored by better help so how's everybody's social battery doing right now?
因为我知道Liquid I.V.已经在我的体内发挥作用了。当然我一整天也会喝别的水之类的一起喝，但把这个作为一早的第一件事，我太爱了。无论你以何种方式补水，都可以在全国Costco批量购买Liquid I.V.补水倍增器无糖版，或者访问liquidiv.com并在结账时使用代码smartless，首单即可享受八折优惠。使用促销代码smartless在liquidiv.com购物，即可享受首单八折优惠，开启更优质的补水体验。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。大家最近的社交电量都怎么样？
Are you drained? Are you bursting with energy? I'm right in the middle. Like sometimes if I feel like I have been too social because I feel like I gotta keep my brain going, I like seeing people, I owe it to them because I love them, because my family and friends or whoever it is, I owe it to them to see them
你们枯竭了吗？还是能量爆棚？我正处在中间状态。比如有时候我觉得自己社交过度了，因为我觉得我得让大脑一直运转，我喜欢见人，我欠他们的，因为我爱他们，无论是我的家人、朋友还是任何人，我都欠他们去见上一面，
and to actually give to them my time because I know it means a lot to them and it means a lot to me when they do it for me. But sometimes you can get run down from that. So it's all about finding the balance of like, how do you take the time from me, but also be there for the people that you love, which is the most important thing in the world.
并且真正把我的时间奉献给他们，因为我知道这对他们意义重大，当他们为我这样做时，对我也意义重大。但有时你会被这些榨干精力。所以关键在于找到平衡：如何在留出独处时间的同时，也能陪伴你所爱的人，这可是世界上最重要的事情。
It can be easy to ignore our social battery and spread ourselves thin, especially with social gatherings picking up after the winter. What's the right amount of socializing for you and how do you recharge? Maybe you thrive around people or maybe you need some more alone time. Therapy can give you the self-awareness to build a social life that doesn't drain your battery. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your battery. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule.
忽视我们的社交电量并把自己搞得筋疲力尽是很容易的事，尤其是随着冬去春来，社交聚会逐渐增多。对你来说，多少社交量才算合适，你又是如何充电的呢？也许你在人群中如鱼得水，也许你需要更多的独处时间。疗愈能赋予你自我觉察能力，帮你建立一个不会耗尽你电量的社交生活。如果你正考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在为你提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的服务。如果你正考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在为你提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的服务。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Find your social sweet spot with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持有执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。通过BetterHelp找到你的社交舒适区。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartlis，首单即可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp，拼写是H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartlis。本节目部分由ZipRecruiter赞助播出。
Daylight savings is here and for most states, that means we're gonna have more daylight through November. By setting our clocks forward, it may feel like there are more hours in the day, but if you're hiring, it doesn't necessarily help you find qualified candidates for your roles any sooner. There's only one way to do that, ZipRecruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless.
夏令时又开始了，对大多数州来说，这意味着直到11月我们都会有更多的日照时间。把时钟拨快可能会让你觉得一天当中的时间变多了，但如果你正在招聘，这不一定能帮你更快地找到胜任岗位的合格候选人。只有一个方法能做到这一点，那就是ZipRecruiter。现在你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartless上免费试用。
As soon as you post your job in ZipRecruiter, they send it to over 100 plus job sites to reach great candidates. Plus ZipRecruiter's smart technology combs through thousands of resumes to identify whose skills and experience match your job post. Spring forward with a new hiring partner, ZipRecruiter, and find top talent sooner. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day.
只要你在ZipRecruiter上发布职位，它就会将其发送到100多个求职网站，以触达优秀候选人。此外，ZipRecruiter的智能技术会筛选数千份简历，找出哪些技能和经验与你的职位发布相匹配。携手新的招聘合作伙伴ZipRecruiter大步向前，更快锁定顶尖人才。看看为什么五分之四在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。
Just go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Once again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. I wanted to get to this because I love, I love, because JB obviously started when, I don't know, God, you were what, seven or something, JB? Ten? Yeah.
只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次重申，网址是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在，让我们回到节目中。我想聊聊这个，因为我太喜欢了，因为JB很显然在——我不知道，天哪，你当时几岁来着，JB？十岁？对。
And so like, so there you go. So he always understands this, that experience. Talk, let's talk a little bit about that, JB. Let's talk about first jobs. First jobs, little house in the prairie. Did your parents drive you to like a million auditions over the hill? Yeah. And yeah, so I just grew up on the venture of freeway, you know, lots of traffic on the
所以，你看。所以他总是能理解，那种经历。我们来聊聊那个吧，JB。聊聊第一份工作。第一份工作，《草原小屋》。你的父母有没有开车带你去翻过山去看过上百万场试镜？对。没错，所以我就是在文图拉高速公路上长大的，你知道，路上有超多的交通拥堵。
way. But that's, I learned how to drive. I paid attention with freeway driving, how to merge late, you know, you kind of skip the line. And then when they weren't able to drive me into the city, I'd have to get on the bus there on Ventura Boulevard, stop every single red light, although it would take me an hour and a half to get in the city, but I have my skateboard, my little head shot in my little manila envelope,
但也就是在那儿，我学会了开车。我在开高速的过程中学会了如何注意观察、如何压线汇入，你知道的，就是那种可以插队的操作。后来当他们没法开车送我进城时，我就得去文图拉大道上坐公交车，每一站红绿灯都要停，虽然进城得花上一个半小时，但我带着滑板、装着我那张小小的演员证件照的马尼拉纸信封，
and I'd get off at like Hollywood and Highland and skateboard the rest of the way. And, you know, but it's for the passion, you know, Kristen, envelope and I'd get off at like Hollywood and Highland and skateboard the rest of the way and yeah You know, but it's for the passion, you know Kristen just the passion of the of the of the craft from jump You just want a passionate young man Was that your experience to like you're going with your folks to audition because your parents were both it worked in Entertainment as well, right? Yeah, my mom really hooked me up because she was a script supervisor. And so if she wasn't on a movie, she would be the guy taking me around, which is a total bitch.
然后在好莱坞和高地大道附近下车，剩下的路我就滑着滑板去。而且，你知道的，这是出于对表演的热爱，你知道，克里斯蒂安，信封，然后在好莱坞和高地大道下车，一路滑板过去，对，你知道的，但这纯粹是出于对表演的热爱，你知道，克里斯蒂安，对这个行业的热爱是从一开始就有的，你只是一个充满热情的年轻人。你当时的经历也是这样吗？你也是和父母一起去试镜，因为你的父母都在娱乐行业工作，对吧？对，我妈妈对我的帮助真的很大，因为她是个场记。所以如果她没在拍电影，她就会带着我到处跑，这简直是个彻头彻尾的烦人差事。
It's just constant and like, yeah. You wanted it though, you wanted to be an actor, yeah? No, she was forcing me into it. I was begging her, yeah. You will contribute to the bottom line of this house. So for Tracy, the script supervisor is the person who keeps their eye on the script, makes sure the actors say the lines correctly,
就是没完没了的，而且——对。但你当时自己也想去，你想当演员，对吧？不，是她强迫我去的。我是求着她放过的，对吧。你得为这个家的经济总收入做点贡献。为了让特雷西明白，场记就是那个时刻关注剧本、确保演员台词说得准确无误、
helps the director in the camera department with screen direction, and if things match, et cetera. Like if you're using your left hand to pick up the glass in all the first three takes, and then the next take you pick it up with the right hand, that's not gonna cut so she'll say, so are you, did you grow up being incredible at continuity? Like would you always match your action?
协助导演和摄影部门控制镜头调度、并确保连戏不出问题的人，等等。比如你在前三个镜头里都是用左手拿杯子，然后在下一个镜头你换成了右手，那这镜头就没法剪辑了，所以她会说，那么——你从小到大对连戏就超级擅长吗？比如你总是能完美衔接你的动作吗？
No, I think it's sort of the opposite where I was always like that shit doesn't matter. Really? Yeah, it was like if that's what you're paying attention to then you're really not doing your job, right? It's that classic. You got bigger problems, yeah. No, I would drive her crazy, we've never're paying attention to, then you're really not doing your job, right? It's that classic. We got bigger problems, yeah. No, I would drive her crazy.
不，我觉得情况正好相反，我总是觉得那破事根本无所谓。真的吗？对，我觉得如果那是你关注的重点，那你根本就是在玩忽职守，对吧？这是那句老话。你有更麻烦的问题要解决呢，对吧。不，我会把她折磨疯，我们从来没——如果那是你关注的重点，那你根本就是在玩忽职守，对吧？这是那句老话。我们有更麻烦的问题要解决呢，对吧。不，我会把她折磨疯。
We've never worked together. Oh, you guys haven't. Oh, you haven't? Mm-mm. Huh, what'd Dad do? Wow. Stage manager. So he did TV, which we always gave him a bunch of crap for
我们从来没有一起工作过。哦，你们没有过。哦，没有吗？没有。哼，爸爸是做什么的？哇。舞台经理。所以他做的是电视节目，我们总是拿这个取笑他，
because we were pretentious movie people. So stage manager, so multicam for studio audience shows? Yeah, he was super into the kind of... He always told us that making movies was like watching paint dry. Oh, yeah. Because it's boring and takes forever and he's like running variety shows. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Did he ever do any sitcoms? Would I have worked with him?
因为我们自视甚高，觉得自己是拍电影的。所以是舞台经理，也就是针对现场有观众的节目的多机位拍摄？对，他非常喜欢那种——他总是告诉我们，拍电影就像是看着油漆变干。哦，对。因为拍电影太无聊了，耗时极长，而他喜欢的是那种快节奏的综艺节目。对，对，对。他做过情景喜剧吗？我会跟他合作过吗？
Because I did a bunch of those back then. I feel like he did mainly like game shows, like Fear Factor, a lot of like award shows, and also talk shows. Like I bet you've worked with him a lot, but like not on anything long. You know what I mean? Like you've probably been on shows that he's worked on.
因为我那时候演过一堆那种剧。我觉得他主要做的是游戏节目，比如《惊险大挑战》（Fear Factor），很多颁奖典礼，还有脱口秀。我敢打赌你肯定经常跟他合作，但不是那种长期项目。你知道我的意思吗？比如你可能上过他工作过的节目。
Are they excited for you? I mean, your success is not new. Were they excited for you? Or was it just like, yeah, we're all in the business. It just kind of just happens. No, they were stoked and tripping on it. And my dad is, but both in very different ways, and kind of like reflective of both of their vocations.
他们对你的成就感到兴奋吗？我是说，你的成功已经不是新鲜事了。他们为你感到兴奋吗？还是觉得，好吧，我们本来就这行，这不过是顺理成章的事？不，他们超级兴奋，简直惊呆了。我爸爸是——但两人表现出的方式非常不同，这也某种程度上反映了他们各自的职业特点。
Like I think as script supervisor, there's a department of one, and that's always like a freak. My mom's like not very social, and like does her own thing, and is like a weird thing. They're always my favorite people on the set though. I know me too. Yeah, me too. Well, they're either like the best or the worst,. I know me too. Yeah, I know me too.
就像我认为作为场记，这是一个人的部门，这总是有点让人抓狂。我妈不太爱社交，总是做她自己的事，是个有点古怪的人。不过他们一直是我在片场最喜欢的人。我知道，我也是。对，我也是。嗯，他们要么是最好的，要么是最糟的。我知道，我也是。对，我懂，我也是。
Well they're either like the best or the worst where you're just like, oh she's gonna like, she's a stickler, she's gonna kill me, or you're like that, you know. Yeah. The keeper of, or you just want to impress them. Right, right, right, yeah. Yeah, with the way you match your action,
嗯，他们要么是最好要么是最糟的，你会觉得，哦，她会，她很严格，她会整死我的，或者你会觉得，你知道的。对。或者是你只想让他们印象深刻。对，对，对，对。对，通过你对戏的方式，
but you said. You're like, did you see that? It was perfect, we only had to do it three times. They must be super thrilled with the way you've been able to transition though from being successful in childhood into a young adult and then into adult. Because as you know, it just doesn't happen that often.
但你说了。你会说，你看到了吗？太完美了，我们只拍了三次。不过大家一定对你能够从一个童星成功转型为年轻演员，然后再到成年演员的过程感到非常兴奋。因为正如你所知，这种情况并不常见。
Yeah, it is weird. I know my mom, like, before she was nice enough to cart me all over town, she was like, do you really wanna do this? We have to pay all this money for headshots., you know, you got to pay me back if this ever works out. And I was like, I will. And I remember her looking in the rear view mirror being like, OK, well, I believe in
对，这确实挺奇怪的。我记得我妈，在我还没出名、她好心载着我到处跑之前，她就问过我：你真的想做这个吗？我们要花这么多钱拍定妆照，你知道的，如果以后成功了，你得把钱还给我。我说我会的。我记得她从后视镜里看着我说，好吧，我相信
you, but you have to believe in yourself. Like the most cliche cartoon version of like the start of something. And I was like, trust in me. Like a poster with the kitten saying, hang in there. Yeah, a bumper sticker. But it does, it works though. That's great. Yeah, but she totally was like, oh no, I'm going to watch my kid. I can imagine now, like, school is so scary.
你，但你必须相信自己。就像那种非常老套的卡通片里某件事开始时的场景。我说，相信我。就像那种印着小猫写着“坚持住”的海报。对，一个贴纸。不过确实管用，效果很好。太棒了。对，但她完全就是那种，哦不，我要看着我的孩子。我现在可以想象，比如，学校太可怕了。
Being just a little guy in the world in every way is so scary. I can't imagine having a little kid and like at five years old you have to be like, goodbye, for so many hours, you're gonna go off on your own, and we're not gonna know what's going on, and you're just gonna have to figure it out. Like even that totally freaks me out. And so the idea of my parents dealing with like me, you know, being like, you're a bad actor,
作为一个世界上微不足道的小不点，在各方面都太可怕了。我无法想象生个小孩子，然后在五岁的时候你就得对他说，再见，要离开好几个小时，你要独自去闯荡，我们也不知道会发生什么，你只能自己去摸索。光是想想这事就让我抓狂。所以我的父母还要应付我，你知道的，比如：“你是个烂演员，
and you're ugly, and you don't get the job. Yeah, yeah. But also like I talk about this a lot too, like you and Jason have this where you're not, I imagine, in awe of things that I would be in, having not grown up and wanting to be in the business when I was older. I still am in awe.
你长得丑，你没拿到这个角色。”对，对。但同时，我也经常谈到这一点，你和杰森也有这种感觉，就是你们可能不会对那些如果我没有在很小的时候就想进入这个行业、而在长大后才接触的事情感到敬畏。我依然心存敬畏。
If I meet certain actors or celebrities or whatever, I'm just like, oh my God, I can't believe, today I can't believe I'm meeting Kristen Stewart. It's crazy, it's really cool. Were you desensitized to that? For example, Panic Room, which I wanna talk about, I love that movie, I've seen it 10 times. And of course, I'm so gay, when the thing was over,
如果我遇到某些演员或名人什么的，我就会想，天哪，我简直不敢相信，今天我居然见到了克里斯汀·斯图尔特。太疯狂了，太酷了。你对那种事已经麻木了吗？比如《战栗空间》，我很想聊聊这部电影，我太爱了，我已经看过10遍了。当然，我是个铁柜同性恋，当那部电影结束时，
I was like, I tried to Google, where did they film that? I love that beautiful house. What a brownstone. Yeah, what brownstone was that? It was a set, right? I'm sure it was a set. It was like a fully functional brownstone built on a sound stage in Manhattan Beach.
我就想，我开始谷歌搜索，他们是在哪拍的？我太喜欢那栋漂亮的房子了。多棒的褐石建筑啊。对，那是哪里的褐石建筑？那是搭的景，对吧？我确信那是布景。那是曼哈顿海滩的一个摄影棚里完全按比例建造的、功能齐全的褐石建筑。
It was every outlet worked. It was mind blowing. It was like in a time where, like as people do this, you just have to be like one of five men who are allowed to do it. But Fincher is one of those people and he just built,
所有的插座都能用。太震撼了。就像在那个时代，就像人们做这件事时一样，你必须是仅有的几个被允许这么做的人之一。但芬奇就是那种人，他直接建造了，
you could have transplanted that. You could live in it. We should honestly see like where the pieces are. Let's build it. But all those walls were They were all they could fly all those walls, right? Cuz all those intricate camera moves they had to I would imagine right the whole thing was like on hydraulics all bit Yeah, I mean, I think they were like also different, but we had like five actual I mean
你甚至可以把它整体搬走。你真的能住在里面。老实说，我们真该去看看那些道具都在哪。我们把它建起来吧。但所有的墙都是 它们都可以移位，所有的墙都可以，对吧？因为那些复杂的运镜，我想象一下，整栋房子都装在液压装置上，对吧？我是说，我觉得它们也不一样，但我们有大约五个实际的——
I don't know if it was five but we had like different panic rooms that were detached from the whole house and then there was One embedded in the actual house that was like totally practical. And then like, there was like, yeah, and then it was just the most elaborate playground for her. Sean, that's what you call when you, in the pantry when you run out of Snickers, you call that the panic room, right? Right.
我不知道是不是五个，但我们有几个不同的安全屋，它们是和整栋房子分离的，然后还有一个嵌入在实际房子里的安全屋，那是完全可以实际操作的。然后，对，然后它简直就是为她准备的最精心制作游乐场。肖恩，你在茶水间零食吃完时，把那个地方叫安全屋，对吧？对。
Wait, but to my point, like when you first of all, got the part, and then at such a young age, and then there's Jodie Foster and you guys are like working together, to me, again, to me I would have been like, oh my God, it's Jodie Foster. But having grown up in the business where you're like, hey Jodie, I'm Kristen, here we go, this thing goes like this and blah blah blah, were you desensitized to it?
等等，但回到我的观点，当你首先拿到这个角色时，而且是在那么小的年纪，然后有朱迪·福斯特，你们一起工作，对我来说，再次强调，如果是我的话，我会觉得，哦我的天呐，是朱迪·福斯特。但你在圈里长大的，你会说，嘿，朱迪，我是克里斯汀，我们开始吧，事情是这样的，巴拉巴拉，你对这些已经免疫了吗？
It was different, like, because I was now being spoken to. It's like, I guess I was now being spoken to it's like I guess I grew up on movie sets like eating Snickers and stuff But I wasn't actually like in front of the camera and being like hey, what's up? How's it going? What are we gonna do now like it was right? so that part was like It was crazy that all of a sudden I was like part of the process because I grew up hanging out with my mom on set All the time and that's kind of why I wanted I mean it is why I wanted to be there and to engage with it.
感觉不一样，因为现在有人跟我对话了。这就好像，我猜我当时是在电影片场长大的，吃着零食什么的，但我其实并不是站在镜头前说：“嘿，最近怎么样？情况如何？我们现在要拍什么？”之类的。所以那部分是——太疯狂了，我突然成了制作流程的一部分，因为我从小就经常在片场陪我妈妈，这也是我想——我的意思是，这就是为什么我想去那里并参与其中。
I can't remember if I was starstruck, like I wasn't, it was, I was like intimidated by just being, having to be like, okay, this is like a job and I have to be like, yeah, for sure Jodie, let's do this, let's rehearse, let's block this scene. But it started off being someone else. But for you was it like kind of like how it was for me, where you, like, had I been older and understood all the adult responsibilities of rent and taxes and all that stuff, the stakes of auditions and the stakes of performing well when at work
我不记得自己当时有没有追星的感觉，我没有，我只是——我只是对必须扮演好角色感到有点畏缩，比如：好吧，这就像是一份工作，我必须表现得像“好的，当然，朱迪，我们开始吧，我们来排练，我们来走位”。但一开始它只是别人。不过对你来说，是不是有点像我当时的经历，如果你年龄更大一点，懂得了所有的成年人责任，比如房租、税收之类的事情，试镜的利害关系以及在工作中表现出色的利害关系，
would be so much higher than as kids, we were like, oh, this is great, fuck, I get to take the day off from school and just kind of like playing around. And so the stakes were like, oh, this is great. Fuck, I get to take the day off from school and just kinda like playing around. And so the stakes were lower. It was more fun and so therefore, it wasn't quite as anxiety inducing. Yeah?
会比我们作为孩子时高得多，我们当时觉得，哦，太棒了，操，我终于可以不用去学校了，可以到处瞎玩了。所以当时事情的利害关系比较低。更有趣，因此也就没有那么容易引发焦虑。对吧？
Absolutely. I think I grew into that. I think when I was, yeah, you know, when you're little and you're just like, yeah, I can do this and everyone else thinks I can. Oh, my anxiety came later. How about for you? Yeah, exactly.
绝对是这样。我想我是慢慢适应的。我觉得当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道的，当你年纪还小，只会觉得：对，我能做到，而且大家都觉得我能行。哦，我的焦虑是后来才出现的。你呢？对，没错。
Of course, it's not to be weird of it, that's definitely just comes with the hormonal surge of like, oh no, do I need to consider having sex now? And I have to consider it, and you're like, well now my life's complete, I'm debilitated. We're life's over. Yeah, it's a lot. Yeah.
当然，这并不是说这有什么奇怪的，这绝对伴随着荷尔蒙的激增而来，比如：哦不，我现在需要考虑做爱的事吗？我得考虑这个，然后你会觉得，好吧，现在我的人生圆满了，我彻底废了。我们的人生结束了。对，事情太多了。对。
But JB, what age was it JB, because you also had the thing when you were a kid of like providing, so like doing when you were a kid of like providing. So like doing the work was a way of contributing. Yeah, I mean, it was difficult because my parents were also in a position of manager in my career and also in my sister's career. And so they were being compensated for that from us as well.
但是JB，那是多大年龄的时候，JB？因为你小时候也有那种养家糊口的情况，所以小时候做演员就像是一种分担。对，我的意思是，这很难，因为我父母在我的职业生涯中也扮演着经纪人的角色，我姐姐的职业生涯也是他们在管理。所以他们也从中拿走了我们应得的报酬。
And so that got complicated because those monies went into you know rent and mortgage and so if we're not working that affects the bottom line for the household. But you didn't know about that you were unaware of that? I did I was keenly aware of it and it was fucking stressful because remember work permits? So what you were just saying wasn't true you did feel like... Well eventually yeah but what at the start, though, at the start, it was all kind of fun and games.
这就变得很复杂了，因为那些钱最后都用来支付房租和房贷了，所以如果我们不工作，就会影响到整个家庭的收支底线。但你当时不知道这些吗？你对此一无所知？我知道，我心里门儿清，这他妈压力太大了，还记得工作许可证吗？所以你刚才说的不对，你确实觉得……好吧，最终是的，但一开始，一开始这都挺好玩、像游戏一样的。
But then as I kind of got into like 14, 15, 16, 17, and school got harder, and you know, remember with work permits, you had, every six months your work permit had to get renewed. And they would renew your work permit based on your grades. You had to hold at least a C average. And that's not difficult, but if you know you have to, it becomes difficult. Especially when you're looking down the barrel of a midterm or final exam where that's a huge percentage of your
但后来当我大概14、15、16、17岁时，学业变得更难了，而且你知道的，还记得工作许可证吗，你每六个月就得续签一次工作许可证。他们会根据你的成绩来决定是否给你续签。你必须保持至少C的平均成绩。这其实不难，但如果你知道你非得这么做，它就变得困难了。特别是当你面临期中考试或期末考试的时候，这占了你成绩很大的一部分，
grade and I know if I fail this test for some weird reason, now I get fired off the show, all those people are out of work and we got no money coming into the house. Did you find that it was hard to keep your grades up kind of dipping in and out of the curriculum? Because I was really good at cheating. Because when you're on the set doing school, it's only three hours a day. It's just you and the tutor and you can kind of hide a bunch of notes. In college, I would be, my eyes hurt from, I would be in those big lecture halls and
而且我知道如果我因为某种奇怪的原因这次考试不及格，我就会被剧组开除，所有人都会失业，家里也没有收入了。你有没有发现，在学业的课程里进进出出，要保持成绩很难？因为我很擅长作弊。因为当你在片场上学时，一天只有三个小时。只有你和家教，你可以藏一堆小抄。上大学的时候，我的眼睛都看疼了，我会坐在那些大的阶梯教室里，
my eyes hurt from cheating because my face would be forward but my eyes would look at the page and I'd be like. And my eyes would, so much pain. Anyway, how are you? You ruined your peripheral vision from cheating. So then, Kristen, so then how old were you when you did the first of the Twilight films? 17. 17.
眼睛因为作弊而生疼，因为我的脸朝前，但眼珠却斜看着纸，我会想。我的眼睛，痛得要命。不管怎样，你最近怎么样？你因为作弊把周边视力都毁了。那么，克里斯汀，你拍第一部《暮光之城》电影的时候多大？17岁。17岁。
I mean. Yeah, I'm years old. And talking to the extent, I'll quote Jason, to the extent to which you're comfortable about, like that process of being part of something that's such a global phenomenon and instantly kind of, again, you've been working since you were a kid, you've been around it, but now you're part of something that is so known and so, like it's kind of. Yeah, now you're famous. Yeah, famous in a way that. Can't go out and around.
我的意思是。对，我……岁了。说到某种程度——我引用杰森的话——在你能接受的范围内，关于参与这样一部全球现象级作品并瞬间——再次强调，你从小就开始演戏，你一直身处其中，但现在你成为了一部如此知名、如此……的作品的一部分。对，你现在成名了。对，以一种……无法出门闲逛的方式成名。
But also in a way that very few people experience, especially at that kind of rate. Yeah, that was, and also 17 is like the most awkward age ever, it's you're just now starting to be like, oh, I am a woman. And like, yeah, I think I always kind of like was super utilitarian about the job because my parents are crew and I was just like,
但也是那种极少数人才能经历的方式，尤其是以那种速度。对，那确实，而且17岁是有史以来最尴尬的年纪，你才刚开始意识到：哦，原来我是一个女人。而且，是的，我觉得我一直对这份工作抱有一种超级务实的心态，因为我父母就是剧组工作人员，我当时就觉得，
yeah, I love this job. It's what I'm gonna do forever. I'm gonna make movies forever. And it's like, it's chill. And then that definitely made things different, yeah. Yeah, I'll bet. But it was, I mean, we have kind of like a cool insulated, like when people ask me about like my high school years
是的，我爱这份工作。这就是我永远要从事的事业。我要永远拍电影。而且这感觉挺酷的。然后那件事确实让一切变得不同了。对，我敢打赌。但这就好象，我的意思是，我们有一种很酷的、被保护起来的感觉，当人们问起我的高中时光
or like my college years, which I didn't do either of, because I'm an idiot. Same. Yeah. Me too. That's like the period of time that I think about. And so it's so weird, because it doesn't feel like I'm referencing myself.
或者大学时光时——这两者我都没经历过，因为我是个大笨蛋。我也是。对。我也是。那正是我常常会想到的那段时期。所以这感觉很奇怪，因为那感觉不像是在回忆我自己。
Like I feel like, Really? Talking about a different time, it's like, it's hard for me to relate to that. It's like so personal, I don't see it from the outside. I'm like, well, I was going through, like... It's just so fucking weird to do everything personal publicly. Yeah, it's like, oh, you know who I was dating,
就像我觉得，真的吗？在谈论一个不同的时期，这对我来说很难产生共鸣。这太私人了，我无法从旁观者的角度来看待它。我会觉得，嗯，我当时正在经历……把所有私人的事情都公开去做，这他妈实在是太诡异了。对，就像是，哦，你知道我在跟谁谈恋爱，
you know exactly what happened. Right. Right, right, right. It's like me saying, where do you live? And you're like, oh, unfortunately, everybody knows where you live. It's like, are you guys asked about your first, like, partners? Every time you do an interview about like, obviously, like the series comes up. It's where I come from. It's like, oh, well, what about that?
你完全知道发生了什么。对。对，对，对。这就好像我问你：你住哪儿？然后你说：哦，不幸的是，每个人都知道你住哪儿。这就好像，你们每次做采访时都会被问到关于你们的第一个……比如前任吗？显然，这个系列总会被提起来。这就是我出身的背景。这就好像，哦，好吧，那那个呢？
And you're like, it's crazy that people are still asking me about that first dude. Well, yeah, you know, I didn't I didn't have that and I didn't go to college either. And I'm the dummy that has like, now I want to ask who is the dude? Like I have no idea. I don't either by the way. Well, you know, it's the proverbial dude. Right, whoever the dude is. But it seems like all you guys in there,
然后你会觉得，人们现在还在问我关于那个初恋男友的事情，这太疯狂了。好吧，是的，你知道的，我没有经历过这些，我也没有上过大学。我就是那个大笨蛋，现在我甚至想问：那个男友到底是谁？我一点头绪也没有。其实我也不知道。好吧，你知道的，这就是那个众所周知的“那个人”。对，不管那个家伙是谁。但你们所有人当时似乎，
like it was such a phenomenon as I remember, I apologize I have not seen them, everybody got famous really fast. It must have been comforting that you guys each had each other to kind of go through it with, and you could kind of lean on one another, because I seem to remember you guys all got sort of an equal level of fame,
就像我记忆中那样，这是一场巨大的文化现象，抱歉我没看过那些电影，每个人都红得太快了。你们能彼此陪伴着经历这一切，并且可以相互依靠，这一定很令人安心，因为我记得你们似乎都达到了同等程度的名气，
and you could kind of go through it together, I would imagine, that there was some sort of comfort in that? Yeah, totally. I mean, like, we were all so different. I don't know, I think about that. I'm like, the first picture that I ever saw of myself in a newspaper was in the post. It sounds like so old school too. It's like, we open the post and there you are, and the cover smoking weed with your dog. And this is like my boyfriend's family. And they're like from Staten Island
你们可以一起经历这一切，我想象中，这应该会带来某种程度的安慰吧？对，完全是这样。我的意思是，我们所有人都截然不同。我不知道，我每次想到这事都会想。报纸上登出的关于我的第一张照片是在《纽约邮报》上。听起来也太老派了。就像是我们打开《纽约邮报》，你就出现在那儿，封面标题是你和你的狗在抽大麻。而这是我男朋友的家里人看到的。他们来自史塔登岛，
and they're like, what's going on here? And I was like, oh, what is going on here? Like the movie wasn't even out yet. I had never been photographed by a paparazzi in my life. I was like, been acting since I was 10 years old and was like, what the hell? And then like we were, I got in trouble and I was like, oh, I think this is gonna ruin everything.
他们就问：这到底是怎么回事？当时我就想，哦，这到底是怎么回事？那时候电影甚至还没上映呢。我这辈子从来没被狗仔队拍过。我当时想：我都演了10年戏了，这是搞什么鬼？然后我惹上了麻烦，心想：完蛋了，这下全毁了。
I'm so sorry. And now weed's legal and I was like, oh, I think this is going to ruin everything. I'm so sorry. And now weed's legal and everything was fine. Right, right. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, but I just thought that was such a big deal. Was there a moment there where you considered, like, things would be so, this was fun, but things would be so much easier
我很抱歉。而现在大麻都合法了，当时我还觉得：哦，我觉得这下全完蛋了。我很抱歉。现在大麻都合法了，一切都好得很。对，对。对，对。对，但当时我真觉得这是天大的事。当时有没有那么一瞬间，你考虑过，如果能回到默默无闻的状态，事情会变得……虽然这很有趣，但如果我能重新过上匿名生活，事情就会简单得多，我还很年轻，完全可以去上大学，去学别的职业。我经历过那种阶段。我当时想：这真的值得吗？我能维持这种成功和收入水平吗？
if I got back to anonymity, I'm still young enough where I can go to college, I can study another career. I went through that. I was like, is this worth it? And can I sustain a level of success and income? And I can get all the way to the finish line because I gotta decide now.
我能一路坚持到终点吗，因为我必须现在就做出决定。
That makes it worth it. Yeah, these are the years for college. So like, did you go through any of that? I have to say, I felt like at the time that I could have redirected energy and become an academic, I was so hungry for more work because the Twilight series itself took forever. We did it over a four-year period. We made five movies. It's probably more than four years, by the way.
这让一切变得值得。对，这些年正是上大学的时候。所以，你经历过那种心理斗争吗？我必须得说，我觉得在那个本可以把精力重新导向、成为一个学者的时期，我对拍更多电影的渴望实在是太强烈了，因为《暮光之城》这个系列本身拍了太久。我们在四年时间里拍完了它。我们拍了五部电影。顺便说一句，可能还不止四年。
Like, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21. Like, those, I wanted to make other movies at the same time so badly. Yeah. I just sort of crashed and burned and barreled my way through those years and just like, was really, like, lacked any balance. I was just like, I was just working constantly.
比如17、18、19、20、21岁。在那期间，我太渴望同时去拍别的电影了。对。我只是在那些年里把身体搞垮了、横冲直撞地熬了过来，而且真的是……完全失去了生活平衡。我当时的想法就是：我一直在不停地工作。
Singularly focused, yeah. Yeah, well. And you had your eyes on the end of that tunnel when you're done with your obligation on the franchise, you could start doing other movies that were a little bit more exciting to you? Well, I couldn't, we all kind of, if we were able to like try to like slam one in in between.
目标极其单一，对。对，好吧。当你在 franchise 中的义务结束时，你其实已经看到了那条隧道的尽头，之后你就可以开始拍一些让你觉得更兴奋的其他电影了？嗯，其实不行，我们基本上——如果我们能设法在间隙里塞进一部的话。
And so that was why it was kind of like such a loaded period because we were like either promoting one of these movies Making one of these movies or trying to shove in something that gave you some like variation and not in terms of what it like was like for other people but just so you could like Do something other than play that one part for fucking six years? but then but then at the at the tail end of that did you find yourself like it was was there sort of a moment of like Relief or just like I'm sure it was a great experience, I don't mean in that sense.
所以这就是为什么那段时期感觉压力巨大，因为我们不是在宣传这些电影中的一部，就是在拍这些电影，或者试图塞进一些能带给你一点新鲜感的东西，这倒不是说这经历对别人来说意味着什么，而只是为了能让你除了连续拍六年那个角色之外，还能做点别的什么！但随后，但在那段时期的尾声，你有没有发现自己有一种……有没有那种如释重负的感觉，或者只是……我确信这是一段很棒的经历，我不是那个意思。
I just mean that just the absolute kind of making five films in four years and everything that comes with that and all the exterior pressures and all the... Did you find that moment of like, fuck, where you could just kind of exhale and kind of take a second? Yeah, for sure.
我只是指四年内拍了五部电影的绝对强度以及随之而来的一切，还有所有的外部压力，以及所有的……你有没有找到那种感觉，就是操，终于可以呼出一口气，稍微缓一缓了？对，当然。
Yeah, yeah. I bet. And then the great news is that you did start to make, you know, films that were, not to disparage those films at all, but films that were very, very different. And it seems a little bit more on your sort of artistic ideals and tastes, for lack of better phrases. I mean, like, your career is just like really fucking exciting.
对，对。我敢说绝对有。然后好消息是，你确实开始拍了，你知道的，那些——倒不是贬低之前的电影——但那些非常非常不同的电影。而且这似乎更符合你的某种艺术理想和品味，如果找不到更好的词来形容的话。我的意思是，你的职业生涯简直太他妈令人兴奋了。
Especially Spencer, I thought you were just incredible. I know, so, so, so good. I couldn't agree more. Unbelievable. Nice to say all that, thanks. No, truly, I mean, your thought of it is just one of our great actors, you know? And that's like not a lot of people come out of
特别是《斯宾塞》，我觉得你演得简直不可思议。我知道，真的，真的，真的太棒了。我不能同意更多了。难以置信。承蒙夸奖，谢谢。不，说真的，我的意思是，在你身上展现出的特质让你成为了我们最伟大的演员之一，你知道吗？而且没多少人能从
franchises like that and then get the kind of credibility that you have earned. And so it's just, it's awesome. Well, it feels like, Kristen, like you've had kind of like three careers in such a, or like four, like you've done so many different things. And now you've got this new film coming out that look, like I said, obviously I haven't seen it yet. It was just at Sundance. I can't wait to see it.
那样的特许经营系列中走出来，然后还能赢得你所获得的这种信誉。所以这真的很棒。嗯，感觉就像，克里斯汀，你仿佛在如此短的时间里经历了大约三种职业生涯，或者说四种，你拍了太多完全不同的东西。现在你又有一部新电影要上映了，正如我所说，显然我还没看过它。它刚在圣丹斯电影节上映。我迫不及待想看了。
Right? How is the reception at Sundance. I can't wait to see it. Right? How was the reception at Sundance? It must have been awesome. It was really fun. It was cool because I hadn't done like a, I think we, what was called like a midnight screening and I was nervous because I follow the sleep in movies past 7 p.m. like no matter what.
对吧？圣丹斯电影节的反响怎么样？我迫不及待想看了。对吧？圣丹斯的反响如何？一定棒极了。真的很有趣。很酷，因为我以前没做过那种……我想我们，那叫午夜场放映，我当时很紧张，因为我无论如何都会坚持在晚上7点以后不看电影、按时睡觉的作息。
And I was like, we have to screen our movie. Like everyone's going to be sleepy and I was like we have to screen our movie like everyone's gonna be sleepy and Sick and like altitude sick and like it was just like a cesspool Everyone's just caught I was just like this is not the time to screen the movie, but it was like it was like Like a real a rumpus room I just couldn't believe it I was like everyone is like fully engaged and like standing up and clapping during parts of me I was like this is I haven't fucking hung out in a theater in this way and forever. Oh wow We'll be right back
当时我想：我们必须放映我们的电影。每个人都会很困，而且我当时想：我们必须放映我们的电影，每个人都会很困、生病，还有高原反应，那简直就是一个藏污纳垢的地方，每个人都在咳嗽，我当时就觉得：现在根本不是放映电影的时候。但现场气氛热烈得就像一个大闹腾的房间，我简直不敢相信。我当时想：每个人都完全投入进去了，在电影的某些部分甚至起立鼓掌，我当时就想：这——我他妈好久没有在电影院里体验过这种氛围了。哦，哇，我们马上回来。
Smartless is brought to you in part by audible audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an audible member, you could choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. People always ask what some of our favorite episodes are
SmartLess 部分赞助商为 Audible。Audible 让你在一个应用中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容或发现全新的东西。他们提供横跨各个流派的令人难以置信的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑与惊悚、励志、健康、商业等等。Audible 是你寻找惊险刺激的音频娱乐的目的地，这里有备受期待的新书以及针对各种惊悚小说爱好者的“下一本收听”推荐。作为 Audible 会员，你可以从整个目录中每月挑选一本书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。人们总是问我们最喜欢的节目是哪几个
on SmartList, and of course, I love all of them. David Spade stands out as one of the many, many, many favorite ones because he made us laugh so hard, and now I get to listen to his book, A Polaroid Guy in a Snapchat World on Audible, and it's so great. It's narrated by him, by David, who I just love, and it's all about like getting older and growing up in the difficulties of navigating the world,
在 SmartList 上，当然，我爱所有的节目。大卫·史派德作为众多、众多、众多最喜欢的嘉宾之一脱颖而出，因为他让我们笑得前仰后合，现在我可以在 Audible 上收听他的书《Snapchat 世界里的宝丽来男孩》（A Polaroid Guy in a Snapchat World），真是太棒了。这本书由他本人，也就是我喜爱的大卫亲自朗读，内容全部关于变老、成长以及在世界中摸索前行的困难，
and he talks about dating younger women, and what it's like to be a dad now, and things like suddenly being the old guy on a set. It's really, really funny and only told in a way that David can tell it. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500-500 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless
他谈到了和年轻女性约会，谈到了现在作为一个父亲是什么感觉，以及突然成为片场老油条是什么体验。真的非常非常搞笑，而且只有大卫才能讲出那种风味。新会员可以在 Audible 免费试用 30 天。访问 audible.com/smartlist 或发送短信 smartlist 到 500-500。访问 audible.com/smartlist 或发送短信 smartlist
to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. Hey, smartless listener, we're supported by Mint Mobile. After years of fine print contracts and getting ripped off by overpriced wireless providers, if we've learned anything, it's that there's always a catch. So, when I heard that Mint Mobile wireless plans
到 500-500。网址是 audible.com/smartlist，或者发送短信 smartlist 到 500-500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。Audible.com/smartlist。嘿，SmartLess 的听众朋友们，我们得到了 Mint Mobile 的赞助支持。在经历了多年的字斟句酌的小字合同以及被价格过高的无线运营商剥削之后，如果我们学到了什么，那就是天下没有免费的午餐。所以，当我听说 Mint Mobile 的无线套餐
are $15 a month when you purchase a three month plan, I thought, what is the catch? But after talking to them, it all made sense. There isn't one. Mint Mobile's secret sauce is that they sell wireless service online. They cut out the cost of retail stores and pass those sweet sweet savings directly to you. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you with premium wireless plans for just 15 bucks a month. All plans come with unlimited
购买三个月套餐时只需每月 15 美元，我想：这其中有什么猫腻？但在跟他们交流之后，一切都通了。根本没有什么猫腻。Mint Mobile 的秘密武器在于他们在线销售无线服务。他们砍掉了零售店的成本，并将这些甜蜜的优惠直接回馈给您。Mint Mobile 来拯救您了，他们提供每月仅需 15 美元的优质无线套餐。所有套餐都包含无限量的
talk and text plus high-speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number, along with all your existing contacts. Ditch overpriced wireless with Mint Mobile's limited time deal and get premium wireless service for just $15 a month. To get this new customer offer and your new three-month unlimited wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash smartless. That's mintmobile.com slash smartless. That's MintMobile.com slash smartless.
通话和短信，外加依托全美最大 5G 网络的高速数据。您可以带着现有的手机号和所有现有联系人，将您自己的手机用于任何 Mint Mobile 套餐。借助 Mint Mobile 的限时优惠，告别价格过高的无线服务，以每月仅需 15 美元的价格享受优质无线服务。要获得这项新客户优惠以及每月仅需 15 美元的全新三个月无限无线套餐，请访问 mintmobile.com/smartless。网址是 mintmobile.com/smartless。网址是 MintMobile.com/smartless。
Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at MintMobile.com slash smartless. Additional taxes, fees, and restrictions apply. See MintMobile for details. Hello, I'm Hannah. And I'm Saruti. And we are the hosts of Red Handed, a weekly true crime podcast.
在 MintMobile.com/smartless 将您的无线账单降至每月 15 美元。需加收税费、其他费用并受条款限制。详情请参阅 MintMobile。大家好，我是汉娜。我是苏鲁蒂。我们是每周真案播客《Red Handed》的主持人。
Every week on Red Handed, we get stuck into the most talked about cases. From Idaho student killings, the Delphi murders and our recent rundown of the Murdoch Saga. Last year, we also started a second weekly show, Shorthand, which is just an excuse for us to talk about anything we find interesting because it's our show and we can do what we like. We've covered the death of Princess Diana, an unholy Quran written in Saddam Hussein's blood, the gruesome history of European witch hunting, and the very uncomfortable phenomenon of genetic sexual attraction. Whatever the case, we want to know
在《Red Handed》的每周节目中，我们会深入探讨最受关注的案件。从爱达荷州学生谋杀案、德尔菲谋杀案到我们最近对默多家族传奇的剖析。去年，我们还推出了第二个每周节目《Shorthand》，这只是一个让我们谈论任何我们觉得有趣的事情的借口，因为这是我们的节目，我们想做什么就做什么。我们报道过戴安娜王妃之死、一本用萨达姆·侯赛因的鲜血写成的邪恶《古兰经》、欧洲猎巫运动的恐怖历史，以及令人极不舒服的基因性吸引现象。无论什么案件，我们都想知道
what pushes people to the extremes of human behavior. Like, can someone give consent to be cannibalized? What drives a child to kill? And what's the psychology of a terrorist? Listen to Red Handed wherever you get your podcasts and access our bonus short-hand episodes exclusively on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. From Wondery, this is The Spy Who. This month, we open the file on Oleg Leleyn, the spy who saved MI5. Lenin's actions changed the course of the Cold War in the 1970s,
是什么将人类推向了行为的极端？比如，一个人能否同意被同类相食？是什么驱使一个孩子大开杀戒？恐怖分子的心理又是怎样的？在您获取播客的任何地方收听《Red Handed》，并通过 Amazon Music 独家访问我们的精选短篇节目，或通过 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry 应用订阅 Wondry Plus。来自 Wondry 的《间谍是谁》。本月，我们将开启关于奥列格·列利亚夫（Oleg Lelyavin）的档案，他是拯救了军情五处（MI5）的间谍。列宁（应为列利亚夫）在 20 世纪 70 年代改变了冷战的进程，
a Russian who defected to Britain after being caught in a love affair that shook the world. His actions triggered the biggest removal of spies by any government in history. It's a story of an overstretched security service in need of a win and a covert plan to bring catastrophe to Britain's streets. Follow the Spy Who on the Wondery app or wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can binge the full season of The Spy Who Saved MI5
他是一名俄罗斯人，在卷入一场震惊世界的爱情风波后叛逃到英国。他的行动引发了历史上任何政府最大规模的间谍驱逐行动。这是一个关于人手不足的安全机构渴望一场胜利，以及一个旨在给英国街头带来灾难的秘密计划的故事。在 Wondry 应用或您收听播客的任何地方关注《间谍是谁》。或者您可以在 Wondry+ 上提前且无广告地畅听整季《拯救军情五处的间谍》。好了，言归正传。那么你现在在寻找什么样的东西呢？因为你现在在尝试各种不同类型的电影，所以当你思考什么东西在吸引你、什么东西在拍电影方面能让你感到兴奋时，有哪些是你一看到就会觉得“操，我想拍那个”的东西？回答这个问题总是很难，
early and ad-free with Wondery+. All right, back to the show. So what are you, what's the kind of stuff that you do look for now because you have, like you are kind of doing lots of different kinds of films and so as you kind of think about what, what's, you know, you know, the things that, that, that attract you, the things that, that excite you in terms of filming, like what are the things that are out there you're like, fuck, I wanna do that. It's so hard to answer that all the time,
你知道我的意思吗？特别是作为演员，你会觉得：当你看到它时你就会心知肚明，然后你会觉得自己像个疯子，因为你会为了让它实现而付出一切代价，但在你看到它之前，你只是在那种临界状态中飘浮，比如：我想要渴望点什么。但我们正开始……我真的很想全力以赴……我的意思是，你知道的，这已经不是我第一次提起了。我一直在发出这种求救信号，表达我想根据我最喜欢的一本书之一来拍这部电影的愿望。而且我很确定——
you know what I mean, especially as an actor, you're like, you know it when you see it and then you feel like a crazy person because you'll just do anything to make it happen, but then before you see it, you're just sort of floating in this liminal, like, I wanna want something. But we're kind of starting to... I'm really gunning... I mean, like, you know, it's not the first I've mentioned it. I've been sort of like sending out this like siren song about wanting to make this movie based on one of my favorite books. And I'm pretty sure...
我很确定在接下来的一两周里的某个时刻，我就可以说：我在做这件事了，我们要把这部电影拍出来，因为我们有资金去拍了，但为小成本电影筹集资金实在是太难了。对。但这并不是你要执导的那部电影，对吧？这跟你正在执导的电影不同？这就是我正试图执导的那部。
I'm pretty sure at some point in the next like week or two it's gonna be something that I can say I am doing this and we are going to make this now because we have monies to do so, but it's so hard to get monies for small movies. Yeah. But this is not the film you're directing though, right? This is different from the film that you're directing? This is the one I'm trying to direct.
这就是你正试图执导的那部。好吧，所以你一直在谈论这个。这就是《水的编年史》。对。对，已经过去很长时间了。那会是你执导的第一部电影吗？对。第一部长片。
This is the one you're trying to direct. Okay, so you have talked about it. This is, this is Chronology of Water. Yeah. Yeah, it's been a long time. Would that be the first film that you direct? Yeah. First feature.
对，第一部长片。哦天哪，太令人兴奋了。我正想聊到这个，JB，因为你们两个，再次说明，有相似之处。你也是在片场长大的，周围都是这个圈子的人，你的父母就在这行工作，你妈妈是场记，你拍过大量的电影而且做得非常出色。你想当导演是在情理之中。
Yeah, first feature. Oh my God, how exciting. I was gonna get to that, JB, because both of you guys, again, there's similarity. You grew up in it, you were around it, your parents were in it, and your mom was a script supervisor and you've made a load of films and done it really well. It makes sense that you would want to direct.
我的意思是，吸引力在哪里，克里斯汀？比如，你是被那种宏观的、需要掌控四个角（即方方面面）、你必须包揽一切的模式所吸引，还是仅仅局限于演员的戏份和扮演一个角色？因为对我来说吸引力恰恰在于前者，以及与剧组有更多的互动。我觉得在我真正热爱拍摄的电影中，
I mean, what is the draw, Kristen? Like, are you attracted to the sort of holistic sort of four corners, you know, you gotta do it all kind of thing, as opposed to just the acting lane and playing a character? Because that's kind of what's the draw for me, and more interface with the crew. I feel like on movies that I really love making,
你有机会成为剧组的一部分，导演也会让你融入到那个创作过程中。这并不总是发生，但有时你会觉得：我们都在共同创作这个作品。尽管显然有人在领头，而且维持的视角来自一个单一的源头，但它仍然让人觉得每个人的手都在以一种平衡的方式
you get to be a part of the crew, and directors that let you into that process. It's like, it doesn't always happen, but sometimes you're sort of like, we're all making this. Even though there's clearly somebody who spearheads and obviously the perspective that's being maintained comes from a singular place, it still feels like everyone's hand is in a balanced way
共同支撑着它的分量。所以作为一名演员，我总觉得导演就在我身边的这场戏里，或者至少——我并不是一直都这么觉得，但当合作很棒时，我会觉得这是我们共同完成的。我不知道，这是一种交流，而我只想跨到硬币的另一面去感受一下：这其实是一样的，但也不是完全相同的职业。它其中包含着一种类似于点燃某人发动机的成分，而且我知道我在这方面会非常擅长。我只是知道如何让人们行动起来，或者说不是人，我知道
supporting the weight of that. And so as an actor, I always feel like the director's in the scene with me, or at least, or I don't always, but when it's good, I feel like we've done it. I don't know, there's an exchange and I just want to step onto the other side of it and be like, it's the same, it's not the same job. There's an element of it that's sort of like kickstarting someone's engine and I just know I will be so good at that. Like I just know how to get people going and like, or not peep, I know
如何给你一个——我的意思是作为演员，如果你在做任何真实的事情，它就会发生，你可以在不站在镜头前的情况下做到这一点，我简直迫不及待地想要去照顾某人并为他们指明一条道路。我现在脑子里正想着一个人和一部电影，所以我真的很想去守护这个女孩正在走的这条路，
how to give you a, I mean like actor, like if you're doing anything real, it happens and you can do that while not being on camera and I just can't wait to sort of like take care of someone and sort of set them on a path. I'm thinking about one person in particular and one movie in particular now, so I just like, I want so badly to just like preserve this path that this girl is on
我想看看她如何利用我所有的想法。我想看看她如何让这些想法变得更好。我想——我只是想，我想知道如何去看待事物。我想，我总是——我总是觉得摄像机应该放在一个不同的地方。我会想：你根本没看到这个。相信我。我知道我没有被理解。就像我——我迫不及待地想从头到尾把一些东西拼凑起来，并且……并且有一个计划，将这个计划传达给团队，成为一个激励者，然后告诉大家：我罩着你们，我们要这么做，如果没有看到效果的话也许请相信我，你们会看到的，并且——你在生活中的其他方面也是这样吗？
and I wanna see what she does with all of my ideas. I want to see how she makes them better. I want to like, I just want to, I want to know how to look at things. I want to, I'm always, I'm always thinking like the camera should be in a different place. I'm like, you're not seeing this. Trust me. I know I'm not being received. Like I just, I can't wait to put something together from the very bottom to the top and just. And have a, have a plan and communicate that plan to a team and be a motivator and just, I got you guys, here's what we're gonna do and just maybe trust me if you're not seeing it, you will and like, are you like that in other parts of your life?
比如，你是不是那个能想出绝妙主意来决定我们在哪开派对、去哪吃晚饭、谁应该出席晚饭以及他们该坐哪儿的人？你是个这么厉害的策划者吗？甲型。对，我完全是个控制狂。我当时就想，如果我能一直把所有事情都设计好。真的吗？
Like, are you the one that comes up with the great idea for where we're gonna throw the party or where we're gonna go to dinner and who should be at the dinner, where they should sit. Like are you a good planner like that? Taipei. Yeah, I'm like a total control freak. I'm like if I could just design everything all the time. Truly?
我得克制住自己，不去对别人说：每个人都该这么做。对，但我觉得“控制狂”这个词，我知道你在这里有点自嘲，但它确实有点名声不太好。我们必须想出一个比“控制狂”更好的词，因为这个词太贬义了，而实际上它更像是——好吧，你就像个他妈的煽动者。
I have to hold myself back from being like, this is what everyone should do. Yeah, but I feel like the control freak, I know you're being sort of self-effacing there, but it does kind of get a bad rap. We have to come up with a better term than control freak because it's such a pejorative when really it's like- Well you're like a fucking rebel rouser.
你就像那种说“上吧，伙计，跟着我走，我有个好主意，你会喜欢的……”的人。你的星座是什么？查查看，我是摩羯座。哦，是的。这对合作来说不太好，但我正在努力改。
You're like somebody who's like, let's go man, like follow me. I got an idea, you're gonna love- What's your sign? Check this out, I'm a Capricorn. Oh yeah. Which is not great for collaboration, but I'm working on it.
我最近……我在想，你们有没有……有人打高尔夫球吗？你们看起来像会打的人。我会，哦天哪。哦，太棒了，我们去打吧。我和威廉都有这种“病”。对，对，对。我也是，但我真的是……
I recently was, I was like, I was hitting, I was at, do you guys, does anyone play golf? You guys seem like someone. I do, oh my God. Oh hell yeah, let's go. Will and I have a sickness. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Me too, but it's so, I'm like fully,
我彻底把我的无名指给弄伤了，因为上面有个我非常讨厌的突起，但它就是消不下去。他妈的什么，等一下。你在说什么？你在说什么？你是认真打高尔夫的吗？我打出过一杆进洞，操！克里斯汀·斯图尔特，我们今天上了新闻了。这绝对是……我从来没打过一杆进洞。我恨你，我一直在打。杰森上周打出了70杆，太不公平了。杰森上周打出了70杆，低于标准杆一杆，太棒了。我从来没打过标准杆——我是说在单洞上打过，但我从来没有在任何球场上打出过标准杆总成绩，甚至连我住的隔壁那个球场都没有，
I totally fucked up my ring finger because there's this bump on it that I hate so much, but it's not going to go anywhere. Fucking what, hang on. what are you talking about? What are you talking about? Are you serious golfer? I have made a hole in motherfucking one Kristen Stewart we're making news today. This is never had a hole in one. I hate you I've been playing Jason shot a 70 not fair Jason shot a 70 last week a one under it was whoo I've never I've never shot a par, I mean, on single holes, but I've never parred any course, like not even the one that I live next to,
这很奇怪，就像百慕大三角一样，因为我能连续抓鸟、抓鸟、抓鸟，然后就会他妈的把事情搞砸，把一切都毁了。我当时就想：哇！你是天生有天赋还是专门学过？你上过课吗？我小时候我爸教我挥杆，后来直到疫情期间我才开始打，
which is weird, like it's like the Bermuda Triangle because I've like birdie, birdie, birdied, and then just like fucking shit the bed and like ruined it. I'm just like, wah! Are you naturally gifted or have you studied this? Have you taken lessons? My dad taught me how to swing when I was little and then I didn't play until the pandemic
然后我就开始没完没了地打。我们当时就是这么干的。所以等等，你在那里的公共球场打球吗？你会去威尔逊·哈丁球场和——巴尔博亚球场？对。你没去过吗？哦天哪。等等。那是什么？
and then I started playing all the time. That's what we did. And then so wait, so you're out there at public courses there, you're going to like Wilson Harding and- Balboa? Yeah. Have you not? Oh my gosh. Wait. What is that?
她给我们展示了一个……听众朋友们，她正在向我们展示当地公共高尔夫球场的标志。对，街头那个三杆洞球场。作为一个纹身纹在你的前臂上。你太酷了。哇，太……而且面积很大。我真的是豁出去了。
She's showing us a... Listener, she's showing us the seal from the local public golf course. Yeah, the par three down the street. As a tattoo on your form. You are a badass. Wow, that is so... It's big too. I really went in.
我和我的朋友们打完球，我们玩得很开心，喝了几杯啤酒，当时我们就想：走吧，我们是最好的朋友。我们要永远做最好的朋友。老实说，这都是我最好的闺蜜。但等等，你是喝了几杯啤酒之后才去纹的这个纹身吗？因为我今天正好在东村物色一家纹身店呢。
Me and my friends finished up and we had this great game and we had a bunch of beers and we were like, let's go. We're best friends. We'll be best friends forever. But honestly, these are my best girls. But wait a second, you got that tattoo after a few beers? Because I was literally just scouting today a tattoo place here in the East Village
我和我的朋友结束之后，我们玩了一场很棒的游戏，喝了好多啤酒，然后我们觉得，走吧。我们是最好的朋友。我们要永远做最好的朋友。但老实说，这些是我最好的闺蜜。但等一下，你们是在喝了几杯啤酒后去纹的那个身吗？因为我今天真的才刚在东村这里物色了一家纹身店
and I said to the guy, I said, what are your hours? He usually goes, well, you know, you're supposed to stay open till about two in the morning, but they get too many drunks in here that want tattoos. And then they come back the next day and they say, hey, can you take this off? Where's the eraser? And so I started shutting down around seven or eight o'clock
我跟那家伙说，你的营业时间是怎样的？他通常会说，嗯，你知道，本来应该开到凌晨两点左右的，但这里总有太多酒鬼想纹身，然后他们第二天又跑回来说，嘿，能把这个洗掉吗？橡皮擦在哪？所以我后来七八点左右就关门了
because you're not supposed to get a tattoo with a little buzz on, but you did. No, no, because it like thins your blood and you don't make, you know, choice choices. But he was a friend of a friend and he's an idiot. And so here we are. But I still like it. I don't know if I've made bad decisions at drinking.
因为你喝了点酒其实是不应该去纹身的，但你还是去了。不，不，因为这会稀释你的血液，而且你做出的决定，你知道的，就不太理智。但他是个朋友的朋友，而且是个白痴。所以我们就这样了。不过我还是挺喜欢这个纹身的。我不知道我有没有做过什么酒后乱性的决定。
Let me think about it. Wait, Kristen, I really want to play golf with you one day. I'm going to get a hold of you, and one day I'm going to take you out to... JB's out of town. Kristen, you can come play with me, because he's not at the club right now, but I can come play with you.
让我想想。等等，克里斯蒂安，我真的很想有一天能跟你一起打高尔夫。我会联系你的，总有一天我要带你去……JB不在城里。克里斯蒂安，你可以来跟我打，因为他现在不在俱乐部，但我可以陪你打。
Yeah, I'm going to retire from golf until October. Well, after you guys golf, Kristen, I read somewhere a while ago that you like cooking. I love cooking. But wait, Sean, you can't change the fucking subject. what else we're gonna talk about golf for you swing the ball Dude you can't just Hijack the conversation you get really hungry playing golf like we just have dinner Yeah, that's I'm saying chili burgers or whatever now you're speaking
对，我打算退隐高尔夫界直到十月。好吧，等你们打完高尔夫，克里斯蒂安，我前阵子在什么地方看到过你喜欢烹饪。我超爱烹饪的。但等等，肖恩，你不能他妈的转移话题。我们还要聊多久高尔夫球的事，你挥杆的事……老兄，你不能就这么劫持对话，打高尔夫会让人觉得很饿，就像我们刚吃过晚饭一样。对，这就是我想说的，辣椒汉堡什么的，你现在说到点子上了
Have you just been playing the public courses or have you gone around to the all the country clubs, too? I've been taken to like courses or have you gone around to all the country clubs too? I've been taken to like one or two really fancy courses. It's a completely different vibe of... It is, right? Yeah, there's some good and some bad. Oh, you don't like middle-aged white guys? I like you guys.
你平时都只是去公众球场打，还是也去过所有的乡村俱乐部？我被带去过一两个非常高级的球场。那里的氛围完全不同……确实是，对吧？对，有好的地方也有坏的地方。哦，你不喜欢中年白男？我挺喜欢你们的。
Yeah, but pervasively I will say sort of on the whole. Yeah, it's pretty... Ah! Anyway, that's so cool. That's so, so, so, so, so, so cool that you do that and we can't wait to play with you. Shawnee, a food question? Yeah. Yes.
对，但总体而言，我得说，从整体来看。对，这挺……啊！不管怎样，太酷了。你做这些真的、真的、真的、真的、真的、真的很酷，我们已经迫不及待想跟你一起打球了。肖尼，有个关于食物的问题？对。对。
So do you cook with butter or oil? Oh, actually it's very weird that you asked that because last night I made a pomodoro and I used a bunch of butter and I was like, I know you're kind of a bit of a cheat, but if you like emulsify shit out of it and it gets all frothy and amazing and you like me so it was really incredible. But this morning I thought you could probably do that with olive oil and it would be just it would be different, maybe less rich, but you still could get that frothy kind of...
那你做饭是用黄油还是油？哦，其实你问这个挺奇怪的，因为昨晚我做了一道番茄意面，我用了一大堆黄油，当时我想，我知道你觉得这有点像在作弊，但如果你把它乳化到极致，它就会变得起泡而且超级棒，你会喜欢的——所以真的太不可思议了。但今天早上我想，你大概也可以用橄榄油来做这个，出来的效果会不一样，可能没那么浓郁，但你还是能做出那种起泡的质感……
Right, Sean? Sean, does your chef agree? Or, I mean, do you agree? It's all about that pasta water. But wait, why would one want to go with olive oil instead of butter? Because it's healthier or different taste? Well, it's also a little more Italian to use oil than butter. Because at least in America, with the butter... Please, take one coffee.
对吧，肖恩？肖恩，你的主厨同意吗？或者说，我是指，你同意吗？关键就在于那些煮意面的水。但等等，为什么有人会想用橄榄油代替黄油呢？因为更健康还是味道不同？嗯，用油比用黄油也更意大利风味一些。因为至少在美国，说到黄油……请拿一杯咖啡。
I like the oil. But wait, are you... Are you Italian guys also taking your coffee? American with the bad Are you one of those people because of Your self-described kind of control freak like you said do you cook for all your friends and like groups of people like do you? Like to command the kitchen Yeah, yeah, I did Thanksgiving this year. Oh, you did? By yourself? How'd that go? Me and my girlfriend did it. Like, and then people brought stuff,
我喜欢用油。但等等，你们……你们这些意大利人也开始喝咖啡了吗？美国人配上糟糕的……你是不是那种人，因为你自称有点控制狂，就像你说的，你会为所有的朋友和一群人做饭吗？比如你会不会喜欢掌控厨房？对，对，我今年包办了感恩节大餐。哦，是吗？你自己一个人？感觉怎么样？我和我女朋友一起做的。然后大家带了一些东西过来，
and it was so annoying because we were so inundated with food, and mine was, like, ours was really great, and then we had all these, like, dishes sort of muddying the waters, and I was like, what is all this bullshit? Yeah. Which is... And their shitty pots and their tacky pans. Again, it's not control freak, it's Dream Maker.
这太烦人了，因为我们被食物彻底淹没了我做的，而且，我们的菜真的做得很棒，结果我们有了一堆这种乱七八糟的菜，把局面搞得一团糟，我当时就想，这都是些什么狗屁东西啊？对啊。这就是……还有他们那些破破烂烂的锅和俗气的平底盘。再说一次，这不叫控制狂，这叫造梦者。
I think it's Dream Maker. Did you do the turkey and everything? Yeah. I hear that's not easy. I have a, I really figured it out. You have to get it in pieces. To do the whole thing is really difficult. But if you get it in different pieces
我觉得这叫造梦者。火鸡和所有的东西都是你做的吗？对。我听说那可不简单。我有一个……我真的摸索出窍门了。你得把它切成块来做。要整只做真的非常困难。但如果你把它分成不同的部分……
and the neck and back are, it's really gnarly to talk about meat and stuff. Like to do the whole thing is really difficult. But if you get it in different pieces and then like the neck and back, it's really gnarly to talk about meat in this way. But are like detached and get that dry brain going. And so it's like all encrusted. So you've done this before? Yeah. Wow.
至于脖子和背部，谈论肉类这些其实挺倒胃口的。要整只做真的非常困难。但如果你把它分成不同的部分，然后像脖子和背部那样……以这种方式谈论肉类确实挺倒胃口的。但是把它们分开，然后让表皮烤得干脆。所以你以前做过这个？对。哇。
Now, how did you get the cooking bug? Did mom or dad cook when you were growing up? Oh yeah, they did a bit. I'm just like, I'm kind of a stoner and I'm just really food obsessed, so like. You get a little snacky and you want something nice. Yeah, and I like playing in the kitchen. But do you guys cook too?
话说回来，你是怎么迷上烹饪的？你从小时候爸爸妈妈会做饭吗？哦，对，他们会做一点。我只是觉得，我有点像个老烟民，而且对食物超级着迷，所以……你稍微有点嘴馋，就想吃点好的。对，而且我喜欢在厨房里捣鼓。但你们俩也做饭吗？
Yeah, well I started baking because I started with a cheesecake and I was like, I want, because I want a piece of cheesecake. His cheesecake is so good by the way. And so I'm sitting there craving a piece of cheesecake and I'm like, I want because I want a piece of cheesecake. His cheesecake is so good, by the way. And so I'm sitting there craving a piece of cheesecake. I'm like, well, why don't I just get off my ass and make it? So I just made it.
对，嗯，我开始学烘焙是因为我从做乳酪蛋糕开始，当时我想，我想要，因为我想吃块乳酪蛋糕。顺便说一句，他做的乳酪蛋糕太好吃了。所以我坐在那儿嘴馋想吃块乳酪蛋糕，然后我想，我想要，因为我想吃块乳酪蛋糕。顺便说一句，他做的乳酪蛋糕太好吃了。所以我坐在那儿嘴馋想吃块乳酪蛋糕。我就想，好吧，我为什么不从屁股底下站起来自己做一个呢？于是我就真的做了。
It's so good. Because the chef didn't show up yet. She usually shows up at four or five. Sean's doing real well, Kristen. Do you ever make shit food like Slappy Joe's? I make Slappy Joe's a lot too. Yeah, I have like, I'm definitely low and high. You're just making fun of the slob.
真的太好吃了。因为厨师还没来呢。她通常四五点才来。肖恩，你最近过得真不错，克里斯蒂安。你平时会做一些像劣质 sloppy joe 这种垃圾食品吗？我也经常做 sloppy joe。对，我这人就是，绝对是雅俗共赏。你就是在取笑那个邋遢鬼。
No, no, wait, you have low and high, is that what you said? Yeah, like I like to be fancy and also like, you know, scuzzy. You go low and high. We have sloppy joes, scuzzy. How are you, now, you know, Sean is in great shape, he's a beautiful man, super handsome,
不，不，等等，你刚才说你雅俗共赏，是这意思吗？对，就是我既喜欢高雅的，也喜欢那种，你知道的，低俗的。你还挺雅俗共赏的。我们吃 sloppy joe，低俗。话说回来，你看，肖恩现在身材保持得超棒，是个大帅哥，超级英俊，
but he does have his little cookie pouch. And that's from all of the fun food that he eats. Why do you have no cookie pouch, Kristen? You're talking like... I have a cookie pouch. No, no, no. I guess what I'm getting to is you don't have like a huge workout regimen that offsets. Like you don't work out so that you can eat. I mean, I have gotten, as I've grown into a reasonable adult
但他确实有点小肚腩。那是他吃的所有那些好吃的垃圾食品造成的。克里斯蒂安，为什么你没有小肚腩？你说话的语气……我有小肚腩。不，不，不。我想表达的是，你并没有那种用来抵消热量的大运动量锻炼计划。比如你不是为了能吃东西而专门去健身。我是说，随着我成长为一个理智的成年人，
who's not a total shit show, I actually do exercise and like cook healthy food and try not to eat the meat. And like, I've incorporated some, it's like, I'm either eating sloppy joes and like drinking Coors and playing Los Feliz three times a day, or I am working out constantly and cooking meat. Right, and depriving yourself yummy stuff for a week or two.
而不是一个彻底的废柴，我其实会锻炼身体，还会做健康的食物，尽量不吃肉。而且我融入了一些……这就好比，我要么就是在吃 sloppy joe、喝着 Coors 啤酒，一天去洛斯费利兹打三次高尔夫，要么就是一直在健身并自己做肉菜。没错，为了维持身材，有一两周时间得克制自己不吃好吃的。
Yeah, or just, I don't know, I kind of like going all in on whatever I'm going in on. Me too, there's no grip. What is your sign, for Christ's sake? Aries. In fact, I was recently at the golf course and this dude that I see all the time there who used to be an actor, he sent us a screenplay of his.
对，或者就是，我不知道，我做任何事情都喜欢全力以赴。我也是，根本没有中庸之道。看在上帝的份上，你是什么星座的？白羊座。事实上，我最近在球场遇到一个经常在那儿见的家伙，他以前是个演员，他给我们发了他的电影剧本。
He's an older man. He's really actually super hot because he's like, he drives this lime green, like hand-painted Honda and like plays guitar out the back, offers a beer and a sock. I was like, no. A beer and a sock? But what are you doing? Yeah, he was like, you want one? Justin Theroux is there?
他是个年纪稍大的男士。他其实真的超级有魅力，因为他开着一辆那种青柠绿色的、手绘的本田汽车，还把吉他挂在车后，问别人要不要啤酒和袜子。我当时就想，不要。要啤酒和袜子？但你到底在干嘛？对，他当时问：你要来一个吗？贾斯汀·塞洛克斯在那儿？
That's crazy. He gave you a? Yeah. He's like, you want one? Justin Theroux is there? That's crazy. He gave you a script and you took it? I gave him my email address. Yeah. I was like, you must send this to me. Good person. But he's cool. And he sent he like sang these songs to me and my friends about our signs. And mine was I it's, man, what is this guy? It's totally like Google, he's on YouTube.
太疯狂了。他给你一个……？对。他问：你要来一个吗？贾斯汀·塞洛克斯在那儿？太疯狂了。他给你一个剧本，然后你收下了？我把我的电子邮箱地址给他了。对。我当时想：你必须把这个发给我。真是个好人。但他很酷。而且他还给我和我的朋友们唱了关于我们星座的歌。我的星座是……天呐，这人到底是谁？这完全就是谷歌能搜到的，他在YouTube上。
But he sang this song called I Am, I Am, I Am the Ram, and all the verses are about I will lead the charge, but also how completely fucking egotistical and arrogant and ridiculous and sort of like. Yeah, so you're not gonna get people like that bothering you up at the country clubs. That's the thing. This is like, I prefer this. We can hang out. Exactly. But it was like really good.
但他唱了一首歌，叫《我就是，我就是，我就是公羊》，所有的歌词都在唱我会带头冲锋，但也唱了我有多么他妈的自负、傲慢、荒谬以及诸如此类。所以你不会遇到像那样的人在乡村俱乐部烦你。就是这样。这就好比，我更喜欢这样。我们可以一起玩。确实如此。但这真的挺不错的。
Like, he really got me and he really like nailed. He really like nailed all my attributes. And so, yeah, like the ram thing. Yeah, it is. I'm surprised. What's what's the animal for a Capricorn? Goat, maybe? See, we have these like annoying horns. We're like these silly little animals with big horns.
真的，他真的很懂我，他真的戳中了。他真的说中了我所有的特质。所以，对，就像公羊那种特质。对，确实是。我很惊讶。摩羯座的动物是什么？山羊吧？你看，我们有这种讨厌的角。我们就像这种长着大角的小傻动物。
Yeah, yeah, I don't like it. All right, we're gonna let you go, but what is your last meal you could have being a foodie if you had to call in one last meal. Is it a pizza? I think for me it would be fries and a pizza, I think. Would it be dessert? Kristen, would it be like a dessert type thing
对，对，我不喜欢这样。好了，我们要让你走了，但作为一个老饕，如果你只能点最后一顿饭，你的最后一餐会是什么？是披萨吗？我想对我来说会是薯条和披萨吧，我觉得。会是甜点吗？克里斯蒂安，会是那种甜点类的东西，
or would it be like? No, I'd go pizza over, yeah. I like the food more. You like salt more than sugar? Primarily, I think so, yeah. But then sometimes you just get... Yeah, sometimes I get a little crazy. No, yeah, I would say probably pizza.
还是说会是别的？不，比起别的我还是会选披萨，对。我更喜欢咸食。你比糖更喜欢咸味吗？主要是这样，我想是的。但有时候你也会……对，有时候我会变得有点疯狂。不，对，我会说大概是披萨吧。
I think maybe like... So like pizza, beer, golf and then video games. That's a perfect Christmas to a day. You just need a van and you're all set. I'm not a gamer. I wish that I was. I'm jealous of people who are into sports and video games. What's your... If you're not playing golf,
我想大概是……所以就像披萨、啤酒、高尔夫然后是电子游戏。这简直是圣诞节般完美的一天。你只需要一辆面包车就齐活了。我不玩游戏。我希望我会玩。我很嫉妒那些喜欢体育和电子游戏的人。如果不是在打高尔夫，
but you're drinking beer, what are you doing if you're not playing golf? Like, are you watching shitty TV or are you... I like to play pool and cook and golf and read and make movies. And that's it. Fuck. That's it. By the way, that's it. That's it. By the way, that's plenty. That's plenty, that's pretty good too. It's a pretty solid line up. You don't really?
而是在喝啤酒，不打高尔夫的时候你在干什么？比如，你看烂电视节目吗，还是在……我喜欢打台球、做饭、打高尔夫、看书和拍电影。就这些。操。就这些。顺便说一句，这就够了。这就够了，这也很不错了。这是一个相当完美的日常清单。你真的没有别的了吗？
Yeah, it's really good, it's really, really good. Sean, what's your last meal? What would you do? Spaghetti all day long. Spaghetti? Yeah. And vanilla ice cream. Christ.
对，真的很好，真的、真的非常好。肖恩，你的最后一餐是什么？你会吃什么？意面，一整天都吃意面。意面？对。还有香草冰淇淋。天呐。
Drinking ice cream, that really got me. That was really funny. Oh, Christ. Kristen, sure, we kept you way too long. You're the greatest. We don't deserve your time. What a pleasure. Yeah, seriously.
喝着冰淇淋，这真的戳到我了。这真的太逗了。哦，天呐。克里斯蒂安，当然啦，我们留你的时间太久了。你太棒了。我们不配占用你的时间。真荣幸。对，说真的。
I'm coming after you for some golf. Don't be shocked when I show up. Thank you guys for letting me hang out. You guys just all hang out and talk for an hour, and then you put it on the internet. That's such a weird thing to do. We do that with my friends. We'll talk about your movie too.
我要去找你打高尔夫了。我出现的时候你可别吃惊。谢谢你们让我跟你们一起闲晃。你们这帮人就这么聚在一起聊上一小时，然后把它发到网上。做这种事也太怪了。我们跟我朋友也这样。我们也会聊聊你的电影。
We'll say your movie again too. We were so bad about promoting. I can't wait. Did we get a date on it yet? Yeah, when is it? I actually do know this. It is coming out on March 8th. March 8th.
我们还会再次宣传你的电影。我们宣传得太烂了。我等不及了。我们定好上映日期了吗？对，什么时候？其实我知道这个。它是3月8日上映。3月8日。
I think, or maybe that's, it's coming out in the beginning of March. It's a spring release y'all. Go see it. She's's something. It's coming out in the beginning of March. It's a spring release, y'all. Go see it. She's in it. She's great. It's Love, Wise, Bleeding. It's Kristen Stewart. The great Kristen Stewart. We don't do this often, but... We're going to give you a round.
我想是的，或者也许是，它在三月初上映。这是一部春季上映的电影，各位。去看吧。她演了……它在三月初上映。这是一部春季上映的电影，各位。去看吧。她参演了。她太棒了。这就是《爱欲释放》。主演是克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。伟大的克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。我们平时不常这么做，但是……我们要给你鼓个掌。
Golf clap. Same to you. We're going to give you a golf clap. Thank you, Kristen. So nice to meet you. Thank you for today. Thanks, Kristen Stewart. You were great. You guys, thank you so much. That was really fun. Thank you for today.
高尔夫式鼓掌。彼此彼此。我们要为你献上高尔夫式的掌声。谢谢你，克里斯蒂安。很高兴认识你。谢谢你今天的到来。谢谢你，克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。你太棒了。各位，非常感谢你们。这真的太有趣了。谢谢你们今天的到来。
And done. The great Kristen Stewart. There's so much, I wish I had her street cred. She's cool, she's happening. The fact that she plays golf is just such a great sort of counterbalance to that. Like, I think it gives golf a great name. You know, it's like, even if you have cool people... Because you think golf is uncool. Well, listen, it does not have a long history of being street creddy.
搞定。伟大的克里斯蒂安·斯图尔特。有很多地方，我真希望我有她那样的街头声誉。她很酷，她现在正当红。她会打高尔夫这件事，简直是对这种形象的一个绝佳平衡。我觉得这给高尔夫带来了极佳的名声。你知道的，就好像，即使你有很酷的人……因为你觉得高尔夫不够酷。好吧，听着，它可没有什么悠久的街头声誉历史。
So you get some cool person like her playing golf, it's great for the sport. I agree, but at the same time, I will say this, like, who gives a shit? I wonder if she wants to go to the Dinosaur Golf. I mean, who gives a shit what people think. What's that, Seanny? She's going to become the new Dinosaur Golf. She's the new Dinosaur.
所以你能有像她这样很酷的人来打高尔夫，这对这项运动来说太棒了。我同意，但与此同时，我也要说，谁他妈在乎呢。我不知道她想不想去恐龙高尔夫球场。我是说，谁在乎别人怎么想。那是什麽，肖尼？她要变成新的恐龙高尔夫球手了。她是新的恐龙。
What we got to do is we got to convince her to come to one of these Pro-Ams with us. Yeah, exactly. You know, and we'll... It'd be a great get. Yeah, well, and maybe on one of her golf trips, she seems like a super fun hang Well, the AT&T maybe gets the celebs back. Maybe next year. Mr. Steve John the great Steve John great Steve John
我们得做的是，我们得说服她和我们一起参加其中一场职业业余配对赛。对，没错。你知道的，我们会……这将是一个巨大的收获。对，而且，也许在她的一趟高尔夫之旅中，她看起来是个超级好玩、适合一起闲逛的人。好吧，AT&T赛也许能把名人们吸引回来。也许明年吧。史蒂夫·约翰先生，伟大的史蒂夫·约翰，伟大的史蒂夫·约翰。
Will will invite Kristen? Yeah But and then on top of that we forget the fact that she's like Academy Award nominated Cesar We're not just who's done like she's done everything from like it's very it's not not rare but it's rarefied air of being somebody who's been part of like massive franchises and then done all these like really cool uh art house films uh you know that have her co-star would be would be one of the one of the few that robert patinson had had a a similar um similar thing yeah not fortunate, because that takes away from their talent, but both of them were able to find some projects that facilitate that transition for them.
会……会邀请克里斯蒂安吗？会的。但除此之外，我们别忘了她还是个获得过奥斯卡提名的演员。我们不只是……她演过各种各样的角色——这虽然不算极其罕见，但也绝对是凤毛麟角——既能参与那种巨型商业大片系列，又能拍所有这些非常酷的、独立艺术电影，你知道的，和她合作过的男主角罗伯特·帕丁森也有过类似的经历，类似的轨迹。是的，这倒不是说幸运，因为这并没有掩盖他们的才华，但他们两个都找到了能够促进他们实现这种转型的好项目。
Yeah, post that. Because like Downey, you could say, but Downey came into it with a huge body of work before he started getting into the Marvel stuff. But really to start as a young actor and come out of that kind of a machine. Hunger Games, didn't Jennifer Lawrence, was she in Hunger Games? Yeah. But really to start as a young actor and come out of that kind of machine. Hunger Games, didn't Jennifer Lawrence?
对，在那之后。就像小罗伯特·唐尼，你可能会这么说，但唐尼在开始接触漫威宇宙之前，就已经积累了大量的作品了。但作为一个年轻演员，能真正从那种机器般的工业化制作中走出来。《饥饿游戏》，詹妮弗·劳伦斯不是也演过《饥饿游戏》吗？对。但作为一个年轻演员，能真正从那种机器般的制作中走出来。詹妮弗·劳伦斯不是也……
Jennifer Lawrence? Yeah, she transitioned well. Great Jennifer Lawrence, you're right. But there have been a few, but it's still rare. Yeah, it's on one hand. You should get her to play golf because you know... Here it comes guys, here it comes. Get ready. Why does it feel like you're reading?
詹妮弗·劳伦斯？对，她转型得很成功。伟大的詹妮弗·劳伦斯，你说得对。但这样的演员屈指可数，依然很罕见。对，两只手都数得过来。你应该让她来打高尔夫，因为你知道的……来了来了，伙计们，来了。准备好。为什么感觉你在照本宣科？
No, no, I'm not. I'm just saying, because, you know, when... God, he can't... He's so proud of it. Go ahead. Golfers sometimes yell that thing at the golf ball, right? Like an announcer will say, like, she's gonna have to get this one to blank, right? If she's gonna... Right? Like when they hit the ball and it's in flight, they go,
不，不，我没有。我只是在说，因为，你知道，当……天呐，他真是……他太为此骄傲了。说吧。高尔夫球手有时会对高尔夫球大喊大叫，对吧？就像播音员会说，她这一杆得打到某某位置，对吧？如果她要……对吧？就像他们击球后球在空中飞行时，他们会喊，
oh, you gotta... Fight! Fight! Fight! Fight! Okay. We will Bite. Bite. Bite. Okay, we will allow. Judges will allow. You think we'll allow that?
哦，你得……咬住！咬住！咬住！咬住！好吧。我们会……咬住！咬住！咬住！好吧，我们允许。裁判们允许。你觉得我们会允许这个吗？
Bite. Bite. No, I will say this, that particular one actually bites. Nice, nice punch up, Willie. Bye. Bye, everybody. Smart. Blast.
咬住！咬住！不，我得说，那个特定的梗确实管用。干得漂亮，威利，说得好。再见。再见，大家。聪明。少一点。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbeco. Smart. Less. Barber Co. If you like Smart List, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wonder.com slash survey.
聪明。少一点。SmartLess 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔马亚夫和本·巴贝科 100% 有机手工制作的。Smart。Less。Barber Co。如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。在你离开之前，请在 wondry.com/survey 填写简短的问卷，让我们了解你。
Are you looking to add a new podcast to your ever-growing podcast schedule? If the answer to that question is yes, or even if it's, eh, maybe, or really anything other than a hard no, let me suggest my podcast, Life is Short with Justin Long. In every episode, we peek inside the heads of actors,
你是否正在寻找一个新的播客来加入你日益丰富的播客收听日程？如果这个问题的答案是“是”，或者甚至是“呃，也许吧”，或者除了坚决的“不”之外的任何答案，让我向你推荐我的播客《Life is Short with Justin Long》。在每一集里，我们都会窥探演员、
musicians, authors, and thinkers to find out what makes them tick and how they find meaning in life. I'm also very curious about some of the heavier, more existential stuff like what emoji they use most often and what their favorite form of a potato is, you know, the important stuff. So join us because, you know, life is short. If you like Life is Short and Life is Shorter, you can listen ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐家、作家和思想家的内心世界，去探索是什么让他们与众不同，以及他们是如何在生活中找到意义的。我也对一些更沉重、更具存在主义色彩的问题非常好奇，比如他们最常使用哪个表情符号，他们最喜欢的土豆做法是什么，你知道的，这些重要的事情。所以加入我们吧，因为，你知道的，人生苦短。如果你喜欢《Life is Short》和《Life is Shorter》，现在就可以通过加入 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondery Plus 免费收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。